why hello everybody it is Friday July
14th it's hot hot hot
out here in Los Angeles 95 degrees here
AC's blowing although I gotta say I'm
just grateful I don't live in the south
because apparently it's like 125 degrees
somewhere there
which
stop the Sun from being hot that's what
I I mean right really that's we can find
a way to do that
but uh that doesn't seem normal 125
degrees did it really get that hot
there's a 150 125 I think it was like
115. I mean that's
that's like not suitable for Life
apparently the ocean off Florida is up
to almost 100 degrees
hot tub level well that's probably not
good and basically the coral there is
all gonna die
and then all the ecosystem is going to
perish as a result of that do we need
Coral though I
do not we really need Coral but
apparently the fish and all those little
planktons and all that crap does guys
no probably not optional
fish are optional what a fish done for
you lately I don't even eat fish
you know I do like whales and dolphins
and they'll die too
otters are very cute
[__]
they might make it the Otters might make
it because they eat like
um oysters and stuff I don't know they
seem pretty resilient
dude Florida ocean temperatures are
peaking at almost 100 degrees I mean
that's that is not natural
the funny thing is that the
conservatives in the South are the ones
that are like denying climate change
and we'll see how they like it this
weekend boy 125.
that feels about right to me boy I'll
tell you what man it's just a warm day
boy
um
Death Valley is approaching 130 with a
low of a hundred
it's just normal stuff
having fun out here thank you to our
sponsors PayPal honey Shopify hexclad
and the one and only gamer sups let's
freaking go shut up uh quickly
um
want I'm wearing the new Teddy pressure
I can finally wear something with green
on it because this is the only day I can
but if you guys want to head over to
teddyfresh.com there's a new collection
that you can shop from go check it out
there's all kinds of fun stuff you know
what I mean just just go to the website
check it out see if there's something
you like I mean you know
can I say
that's it
thank you
thank you so much
yeah so the title is pretty provocative
obviously and I'll be honest with you
guys
I was ready to move on
from the Colleen topics you know we had
good
we had good titles for today we had the
danchler
okay which is a big segment we've been
cooking up the dancer it's morphed the
The Bachelor chair for Dan
right
the Dantzler
um and we're still gonna do that but I
mean who am I to deny a good thumbnail
and title especially when it's true it's
not even clickbait you know
this whole Colleen thing has turned into
such a fiasco for me toxic
girl you could say that again
the toxic gossip trash okay don't say it
again I've had enough
I've got a show to do the toxic okay
you're just trying to claim my [__]
again
[Music]
Colleen get out of here
are you supposed to be in hiding or
something
thank you uh Eli's not here today
because she's at a big photo shoot we're
doing and Olivia's on the soundboard
because Zachary
is at a wedding it's indeed
that was pretty nice usage back there uh
uh uh uh Olivia
in fact you're muted Olivia
yeah Olivia go ahead here I am muted you
go ahead oh thank you I said it feels
literally awesome
here thank you for the opportunity
absolutely you know we we believe in you
thank you and so just stay away from the
Flocka button because that is
copyrighted
the the Flocka yeah that that has a
trademark oh got it yeah yeah yeah the
the author lives in this building I
wouldn't want to disrespect also um
uncle Gabe is here hello Uncle Gabe
hello Friday baby
it is a it is a wonderful beautiful
Friday but uh it's a bit of a solemn day
isn't it Gabe yeah I just want to say
something
don't say the word though just say if
you have to refer to it just say the F
word
yeah on my recent Cameo
um my Cameo video I didn't mean to
offend anybody if you get offended it or
oh you guys get offended I'm really
really sorry
I apologize for
it's the academy is just a post you know
they want me to like roast people do all
that stuff and I didn't know that f word
is really offensive you know and I want
to apologize and I'm sorry that's a good
apology Gabe that's heartfelt I
appreciate that
yeah
oh you oh you're gonna do a ukulele
apology okay perfect yeah
oh
my God I'm sorry
I'm sorry what to do
yes I'm sorry I'm sorry sorry sorry I
didn't mean to offend anybody and I
apologize because I'm sorry
I didn't know that f word was offensive
but I am really really sorry I apologize
I'm gonna apologize and I'm sorry go on
that was beautiful you know what's funny
the apology felt super sincere and
genuine and then he took out the ukulele
and then it didn't
well you know what Colleen didn't even
apologize in her song Gabe's doing
something new yeah he did his own thing
with it that's true no Gabe I I know you
mean I knew you mean well there was a
cameo that surfaced that people were I
guess some some people were offended by
and I understand because the f word is a
slur against gay people
and uh Gabe dropped a few f-bombs
um and uh well now we know and Gabe has
made a sincere apology and I I feel that
I mean obviously I'm not gay so it's not
it's not really directed towards me per
se but I
as a straight man unaffected I forgive
you and I think I speak for the whole
gay community that they forgive you as
well
right guys
and I didn't mean I'm sorry if I
offended everybody I've seen that Cameo
video
yeah so um anyway well now that it's I
mean do we have are we gonna have like a
solemn Friday are we going out still and
having a fun Friday are we going to just
sit in silence and uh reflect yeah just
reflecting on kind of the the word that
we used
I just want to say
yeah
what is it that you wanted to say
I just want to say you know
I just I don't I don't mean any harm I
don't mean any um yes right
yeah yeah
can you throw up a poll yeah
okay I'm gonna do a pull for our gay
fans say if you're members of the lgbtq
plus Community do you forgive Gabe yes
no or a c option I'm not I'm not a
member of that community
there's a password to get in they'll
know
yeah we will need proof of your gayness
they'll know
send us a picture
[Music]
okay
so hold on Gabe I'm gonna get a pulse on
the nation here we're gonna find out so
I'm not a member I'm gonna click that
but uh all of our our
queer uh lgbtq plus Community guys if
you we can get our votes in here do we
forgive Gabe and uh so far it's looking
overwhelmingly yes
and the only reason the yes isn't at a
hundred percent Gabe is because I'm not
a member has 36 votes so I think you're
you're good just stay away from it in
the future you know
yeah you're good though we offered okay
yeah
all right
yeah baby
Friday is the only f word we know in
this house can you smash that ukulele is
that a family heirloom or can we rock
and roll that it's a it's a family thing
oh it's a family heirloom okay
I don't want to destroy it
but don't you want to say
it's Friday baby
and let's get a special message to our
gay fans let's turn up this weekend
[__] oh rich
welcome this is good Rich luck says [__]
you Dan
yeah
he donated he said as president of the
lgbtq plus Community we forgive you love
and light well that's God
that is huge
I love Rich Lux same
pure luxury
all right gabo
awesome
yep
the loud clicking of the camp Ian's do
you usually switch that loud
it's just like dude it's usually not
dead silent for extended periods of time
in here all right Gabe you have a great
weekend we love you buddy okay you have
a good weekend take care bud be good be
good out there be good out there
thank you
Karen says it's her uh she turned 32. we
need we need proof although Zach's not
here
she said can she just get a birthday
thing from you Olivia say it again she's
32. Miss Colleen Aaron
yeah what you got to play sound for her
do you have a 32 oh obviously obviously
I'm 32 [__] you I don't know how Zach
has it how does he do that I don't know
I don't know he's in it I don't think he
has one for every age so if you just
type in 32 yeah he has one for you oh
here
[__] you there you go perfect perfect
wow well done prepared no he is he he's
very prepared that wasn't me that was
all Zach
all right guys so let's see here um glad
we got that out of the way huh
Gabe's a good man you guys yeah you know
what I mean we know his heart is pure
right
so let's talk about this I guess Colleen
Ballinger lawyer nonsense
now obviously these people once again
they just don't get it
I was moving on you guys I was done
talking about Colleen
and now here we are once again with
another thumbnail another title
and you guys can't even blame me right
like this is pretty juicy you guys can't
even be like yo stop talking about
Colleen already it's like the fifth
video in a row it's like well yeah they
sent me a you know and then if they have
a private eyes
um you know tailing me then I'll make
another video about it just saying
so this all started when um
Ethan's basement which is a fan Channel
uh made a tweet or something because I
had not received this letter
in fact
I'll go as far we checked all of my
emails we received it last night at 8
30.
before then
her her brilliant lawyer had sent this
cease and desist
to Ethan's basement
just reflect on that for a moment
you know
not the public email address I have for
work that I check regularly
you know
not my main email that I check
associated with my YouTube account
no Ethan's basement okay
well he's a traditional media lawyer as
I understand it so the Boomer energy is
strong what was that I like that yeah
that was pretty good
I think I need music that would have
dropped in music by now and it gets me
in the mood that was kind of kind of
good
no I like it I feel like I'm in
Battlefield yeah I like it survive kind
of inspiring and kind of triumphant yeah
I like it getting ready for war we're
not ready if we're not sure if we're
going to war but we're preparing right
so Ethan's basement uh
oh I don't know is this Twitter where is
this Facebook I don't know I think it's
YouTube YouTube Community Post Yeah okay
hey podcast Colleen's Lair lawyers think
I'm you and sent me a cease and desist
email asking for Mr Klein what should I
tell them cheers my dude love you
um so my first reaction when I saw this
was like man there's no way
now I know Ethan's basement this guy
wouldn't lie he's a good dude yeah you
know him right we've been uh we've been
shouting a little bit behind the scenes
and yeah he's he's an honest person yeah
so I was like well I'm sure so my
initial thought was like it's probably a
troll because the troll people have got
pretty good at making stuff look real
and I mean for God's sake so I'm pretty
sure that though this whole calling
claiming thing was a troll so they're
out there
but so what I tweeted out I guess in
response
wait this isn't me
this is actually products
I typed h3hc why the [__] would this be
the first result for ducaton
you know a bunch of uh famous people
follow him or like people who think like
verifying people yeah I think Stevo is
one of them oh my God yeah I can't say
anything bad about it but Steve
let's see if it shows us his famous
followers
I guess I can I can't organize it by
right I don't think so by Falling but um
let me just make sure he's not dropping
n-words or something
congrats on your 20 year old girlfriend
48 year old Boogie I mean that's fine
this guy is pretty off the rail
sometimes with peace and love this is
how you do an apology oh God what is a
little bit of a break
two weeks to be uh exact it's just a
it's just the clip from our episode his
engagement is weirdly good like the set
5 000 likes yeah this is probably 2 000
likes probably because he's the first
result when you uh this is the real
producaton this one has eight thousand
like what the [__] this guy gets more
likes than me what people think he's you
right I guess um I sometimes get tricked
yeah me too yeah uh Productions just
keep it PG-13 please
thank you he's a good guy too I'm not
gonna you know all these guys yeah
awesome yeah you're the Kingpin you're
the one that made it yeah I'm yeah I I
am that's why everyone is trying
so this first started uh I tweeted it
about it I said I'm assuming this is
fake until I see it because I can't
imagine her lawyers would be dumb enough
to send it to a fan Channel but if it's
real let's go
so this uh morning I'm her biggest fan
the first thing I I thought of when I
woke up was like all right because last
night he wasn't getting back to us it
was too late I understand
so first thing I wake up I check at the
updates
[Music]
and uh sure enough
it's real as a
it says real as
let me think here I was gonna say it's
as real as Cav's donation at Habitat for
Humanity but that was not real right
that wouldn't be a good analogy
as real as kavcabs wet and Reckless
charges
those are real those are real yeah those
are so real
those are as real as true and straight
and hard as Brad the Bulls [__]
hell yes not good I liked it no that's
real I think it's like a stretch you
know he's hot you know he's got a hog on
him for real the ball he did two of you
at the same time that's real that's real
it is it is it's real it's just a Vibe
yeah we all know yeah I guess if anyone
would know you guys wouldn't know so
um now the first thing I thought was
like okay this is real okay interesting
so
what I find interesting first about this
here's the email of course why wouldn't
I show it
I blurred out um the lawyer's email
because um
I'm not trying to give shade to the
lawyer I'm not doing that anymore yet
just kidding you're reasonable man I'm a
reasonable man you know I'm not trying
to cause any trouble I'm just trying to
you know
listen I'm a very open person yeah the
lawyers need to know that about me
and the last situation you asked you
asked them are you sure you want to go
through with this yeah with which one
bbtv and now I'm 620 000 richer oh yeah
dude
but apparently her lawyer is
somewhat of a high-powered individ or I
don't know high-powered by a
let's say it's a big entertainment
lawyer yeah he is this the guy who's who
represents what
are you are we saying who it is or not
because as soon as you say that you've
said who it is okay I won't go there I
mean we talked a lot about it on
Wednesday
but okay whatever my first thought was
um
he represents a
um someone who is potentially
accountable allegedly
that's alleged right that was alleged
that's a let well it's no this is his
lawyers I don't want to miss me it was
like a fetish that it was a crazy fetish
allegedly he was he liked cannibal plays
yeah play I don't yeah we'll say that
just pretend cannibalism okay he we are
yeah so
he ate with that one who else does he
allegedly represent
[Laughter]
say his name right now I don't want to
say his name okay
was it Kevin Spacey or someone else
no not Kevin Spacey no Bill Cosby no not
Bill Cosby no
well anyway I was like so the letter
this is really interesting the thrust of
the letter is they want us to clarify
that she did not
upload and claim the music
what now what I find compelling about
this is that they don't care about the
all the other stuff right
it's just the CD Baby [__] they've
established too far Not The Grooming
not the brother is a pedophile well
yeah I don't know I mean they may be
planning on suing the kids instead I
hope not but you're probably right based
on the gearing up I'm seeing here yeah
well if she does do that well we should
definitely crowdfund yeah for them
because I know from first-hand account
how [__] up it is to get sued from
someone with money when you're broke
or well I guess I don't because Matt
Haas didn't really have money but get
sued when you're not when you're not
when you're broke
oh [__] wait he did represent Bill Cosby
allegedly
for real yo he represents Brian Singer
oh yeah yeah yeah yo this guy really
rubs shoulders with some of the greatest
man if I found out that my lawyer was
representing these guys I'd be like
maybe not you
Brian Singer
prince Andrew that is so sick you're the
legend bro and add it to the list dude
it's almost Danny Masterson oh
going to this lawyer is basically an
admission of guilt
allegedly
we love him with peace and love we love
him it's not an it's not that I'm I'm
just doing an opinion thing right
because he's probably watching this now
so it's all an opinion thing I'm a
comedian you know what I mean thank you
exactly we have a whole opinion
uh collage
just so you
for sure couldn't mistake it
but yeah she's in great company man
what's Chris Noth what did Chris Noth do
okay nothing apparently he's innocent
Chris Noth is innocent I never heard of
him
but uh
Brian Singer doesn't get much worse than
that
let me ask you this lawyer what whoever
you are
you represent Brian Singer would you let
him babysit your kids
he's like no but I let him pay at me
okay all right he's settle down Ethan
I'm not trying to pick a fight with
anybody
I'm here to I'm actually here to bury
the hatchet if you can believe that
yeah but I have a problem I've gone over
this before I don't respond well to
these types of things
you know
he's the rapist he's the rapist rapist
you know like amongst the rapist
community
he's the one where they're like this is
the guy the good girl
in my opinion all alleged I think
they're all innocent
fart joke
oh man see this is I have a problem
it's my problem and it's their problem
so um
shout out all right let me just read
this so we can hopefully not stay on
this too long
stop laughing at Sonic that was really
quiet
I had to turn the music way down because
it was too loud oh but I need some Hype
music so can we figure that out well the
music's still playing but I have it low
but I can't hear it
I need to hear it
I need to get hyped
it's too quiet I'm not feeling the
excitement
okay now I'm excited now it's awesome
thank you that is over stimulated now
I'm excited now it's too loud can I say
that is that okay yeah you can yeah
thank you
all right so here's the letter that was
sent to the fan Channel and then was
sent to us last night at 8 30 PM which
is after I tweeted I think so
like I'm pretty safely I'm pretty
comfortable saying and to the best of my
knowledge that we did not receive this
email until
let's see this first one was from 19
hours ago
that predates 8 30 last night
right
19.
um
divide by four
times four
divide by 11.
I think so someone want to Crunch the
numbers back there for me what time was
that tweeted up
I don't have a lot of help today I'm
crunching
I'm floundering out here
it's is it's okay
so so no
you guys still thinking on that one what
are you asking I'm I'm doing with audio
today well you're not yeah you're not
the only one sorry I was I was checking
something else that was said
what is it that you want to know okay
I'll figure it out myself thank you guys
oh God damn it says Productions again
6 p.m I think 6 p.m yes
yeah it says yeah it says the time here
6 p.m so he's so he didn't send the
email until two and a half hours after
this right
thank you uh well they sent an email
they tried to send an email to us uh the
day prior but they didn't send it I
don't know where that got sent
it's not in my work email that's what
I'm saying my emails when the Ethan's
basement guy forwarded us the um the
email that he received in in uh the
down in the email quote or whatever you
could see the original email that they
tried to send to us and it was time
stamped on Tuesday did they show the
email that it doesn't show where it was
originally sent okay so they said
they're just like Ethan ethan.com
that'll reach him
so anyway this is the email at long last
let's take a look
Dear Mr Klein you may know some of my
clients
so therefore you should take this
seriously for example Army Hammer Chris
Noth Danny Masterson Brian Singh prince
Andrew he didn't say that he didn't say
that no that would be funny though he
says uh Dear Mr Klein our our Law Firm
is litigation Council to Colleen
Ballinger
we are regard writing regarding a recent
episode of your podcast in which you
falsely reported that Miss Mrs Ballinger
submitted a copyright claim based on
your prior use of her song
you also falsely reported that Mrs
Ballinger uploaded the song to CD Baby
for sale near those statements is true
nor do you have any information support
to make those claims on your podcast
well that's not true I do in fact I
tweeted it out and these guys really
Colleen I don't know what you're paying
them but
they're not doing enough
you know
let me go back literally from YouTube
uh here's the what I got
um
it says toxic gossip train
okay Colleen Ballinger this is literally
from YouTube
okay on behalf CD Baby on behalf of
Colleen Ballinger now if there's a
problem with this which by the way I was
very upfront in saying yeah it's a
strong possibility that she's not even
responsible for that so I feel like I
was
fairly gracious and fairly truthful in
terms of the potentiality that this was
actually her and frankly I I want the
truth too I don't want her to being
blamed for something she didn't do
so
so but let's continue so they says
neither of those statements is true nor
do you have any information to support
making those statements on your progress
I do absolutely I do
I think you call those receipts in the
legal uh in the law world
uh you know the receipts like uh
I shouldn't make that joke I really
shouldn't
I shouldn't do it no let me type it you
guys tell me I know you guys are gonna
say no but
I don't know it's not even that funny
potentially but it's probably I
shouldn't say that no don't I mean it's
just a joke
thoughts Dan I did
you if we're getting sued you've already
done what you need to do to get sued so
I don't know I've been good you have not
been good this is all I've ever how have
I not been good
you are attack you were attacking this
lawyer saying no what is he going to sue
me for being a meanie I maybe that's why
I was distracted I extremely just people
Sue like okay well you know this
lesson dude I'm sorry but Colleen
Ballinger does not scare me I'm being
sued by a billionaire okay then he said
the receipts like Brian Singer has I
didn't say you read it now I know I'm
just saying I think it at this point all
bets are off go ahead read it there's
the receipts like Brian Singer has for
kids toys that's a joke yeah that's not
an actual allegation
thank you Dan
didn't need to read it
I don't think that that I'm trying to
say that's not the thing that's going to
get you sued everything I've said is
jokes bro it's all alleged I don't know
anything in all my opinion
I'm not saying they would win but we'll
get in line [__] you know what I mean
it's basically like part of my
personality at this point it's like hey
it's Ethan I'm gonna get the record for
the most suit [__] on YouTube the
highlights has been doing great so I say
keep it coming
unfortunately the settlements can turn
out to be a lot more than anything yeah
but I don't I don't care fair enough
listen the thing is
I believe in the First Amendment
and I say Give Me Freedom or give me
death right Dan fair enough I mean it's
your money
right exactly it's my mind
although with you reading that statement
they may be able to come after you
personally no no I everything I say is
on behalf of Ethan Klein Ellis that I
disavow
employee
do not represent uh the interest of this
company
but anyway
um
you know what's kind of funny though
I believed them that she it wasn't her I
believe him I believe him too and I said
that before but what's funny especially
though it hasn't finished publishing but
after seeing the CD babies process for
getting [__] on platforms like yeah it
does seem like it's not that hard to
troll like that well what's funny is
they're sending me assistance assist we
literally redid an experiment to show
how easy it is to do that too
um acquit
Colleen Ballinger yeah we were trying to
clear her name like come and do her a
favor like I'm I'm here for the truth
and the truth only
now if you're wondering about the truth
about Brian Singer
what's that documentary called
that open secret or something
I don't know if that one included him
there's one about him or it has him in
it about the predators in Hollywood it's
called an Open Season okay
an open secret documentary now if you
guys are looking to learn about
some really disturbing stuff about Brian
Singer an Open Secret potentially would
be a good watch for you
I'm not I don't know if anything in that
document is true or not
I didn't make it
that's 88 of Rotten Tomatoes though so
people did like it
that's hard
I mean I've always despised Brian Singer
so I feel it's a good in a way to have
almost this I have here what almost a
revenue to speak to him in a set like
I've always thought in my opinion that
Brian singer's a [__] pedophile
right that's that's just based on what
they told me oh that's just in my
opinion because it's been alleged
watch I'm gonna get sued by Brian senior
now it's so funny
well hold on what's the revenance for
that just so I can say I mean I'm
alleging it in my opinion
but there is evidence right okay that
was a bit much I think I would have to
dig in I I don't know off the top of my
head all the details of that I mean here
the Atlantic I mean the middle
documentary about it so I'm sure Brian
singers accuser speak out
because this guy was like mainstream
mainstream and meanwhile like the most
heinous accusations you can imagine this
guy was up to and like even up to
recently didn't he direct uh
uh
it all fell apart for him during the uh
whole Queen movie Queen movie that was
not that long ago it wasn't that long
ago you know
but uh he says nobody's gonna believe
you though Bohemian Rhapsody director
Brian Singer has been trailed by
accusations of sexual misconduct for 20
years here his alleged victims tell
their stories so maybe not a maybe not a
pedophile oh he was accused of essaying
miners
but let's make sure there's not a
correction here
that's why I got sued by cavcaf let's
see and let's go to the bottom
um
we have a correction here Brian this is
a very thorough article my goodness
it just says it just says this article
appeared in March 2019 print edition
with the headline nobody's going to
believe you so it doesn't appear to be
any corrections but
I'm not making any claims at all you
know what I mean
that's just my why is we got to get my
opinion on the screen guys even when I'm
showing something
look this is a the Atlantic's opinion is
this where'd you find this photo
you just Google Brian Singer creep and a
bunch of photos come up oh dude you're
really dressed as a priest you sick [__]
you [__] monster you
feel free to inform your own opinion
around it
wow
yeah I've always despised Brian Singer
he's one of the most wretched people it
seems to me alive so shout out
but everybody deserves to be um
Everybody deserves to be defended right
I guess
what's kidding
I mean everybody deserves a legal
defense no no I hit the note button but
I said kidding kidding
so
uh it's taking me a while to get through
this oh gosh this is one we've only made
it through one paragraph
this is the problem is like I could have
done this in like five minutes
but how long have we been going now 35
minutes 35 minutes yeah and I've got to
do a second I've even got to the second
paragraph
in fact I might have to take an ad break
and then come back to it
all for a story that uh pretty much is
just that it's nothing happened I was
that a story no that something did
happen they sent me a cease and desists
that's a big deal hey girl what's the T
excuse me Dan don't down downplay this
we clickbait [__] this is not one of
those times
oh so I was going to say something's
interesting he says you falsely reported
that Miss Ballinger uploaded the song
City baby for sale neither of those
statements is true nor do you have any
information support make those claims on
your podcast so not only do I have those
claims what I find interesting is they
didn't provide any proof
that she didn't do it
so like I can't sit here and say oh the
bird what the burden of proof is on the
person making the claim
what no I have evidence from YouTube
I'm not making it up YouTube sent me an
email to Colleen Ballinger claimed your
[__]
so if they're saying I need you to say
that that was a lie I can't sit here and
tell you with 100 certainty that
is a lie because YouTube sent me that if
I would need some kind of proof now do I
believe them I do believe them but I
can't with 100 certainty say that she
did not claim those songs and then later
regret it
I can't say that that would be a
question for
CD Baby or kid disco or whatever the
[__] you know what I mean the strip kid
yeah
that's true
oh and then I mean here you can say even
um golly this was yesterday before this
lawyer stuff even started I said Colleen
or whoever was impersonating her
right
has dropped the claim
and so
you know again this has been part of the
narrative from the beginning
okay
lawyers don't expect this reaction when
they email people I bet I don't think
they ever
they never met somebody like me I'm like
a lot I'm like the genie baby you ain't
never
met I had a friend like me and a friend
left me I'm like the genie of [__] I
come out of like a [__] clog [__]
toilet
careful what you wish for
uh Miss Ballinger did not upload the
song to see baby apple music or any of
those other streaming platforms for sale
for any purpose
Miss Ballinger has not monetized the
song in any way we don't know who
published it to those streaming
platforms
okay it was done without Miss
Ballinger's knowledge or authorization
and we took measures to have the content
removed thank you and it seems that your
efforts resulted in the claim being
dropped which I appreciate and I thanked
you
likewise Miss Ballinger has not issued
any copyright infringement claims to you
or to anyone else that featured her
video song
we demand that you promptly publish a
retraction I guess this is technically a
retraction
well it's not a retraction it's not even
really a correction because I feel like
we were correct
uh
in the beginning and refrain from making
unsubstantiated claims about our client
going forward
um okay well I don't plan on doing that
we'll just stick to the grooming that
you did yeah yeah right it doesn't
substantiated yeah
I mean it is the grooming claims are
actually highly substantiated yeah in
fact we had three
first-hand accounts of it that's correct
show yep but don't you I just don't you
find it endlessly ironic that they're
like hey the CD Baby [__] I mean it's
hilarious it is ironic and it's and it's
a bit funny
um but yeah I mean they they're they're
denying the stuff that they're able to
deny
right and and the other stuff and
staying quiet
yeah I don't know we don't remember
anything I don't remember nothing about
nobody
uh so yeah so so they say that she
hasn't filed copyright she hasn't sought
to monetize and I believe you guys
genuinely I do
so uh I'm happy to put this out there in
support of that notion I don't believe
she did as I've said from the beginning
I've been very vocal about that
um and so yeah I believe I believe you
guys now I I don't know what for sure
you'd have to show me some kind of proof
maybe some kind of emails or
correspondence with CD Baby
where they can show
like we don't have an ID or we don't
have any identifying information for the
person who claimed these that would be
compelling that would be more compelling
than I say okay I'm pretty sure 99.9
okay but I'm not in the business of
making definite statements
anymore anymore
I learned my lesson
although here's one thing I can say for
sure Brian's singer I'm just kidding
you knew what I was going to say but I
didn't say it
I was going to say something he's a good
director he is that's the thing about
him I like his movie he's okay he's mid
I don't know he made one good movie if
we're being honest he made the X-Men
movies which I like I always thought
those were kind of mid which is the one
that you liked Usual Suspects oh I mean
that's iconic yeah it's great with his
good friend Kevin Spacey that's correct
the two greats coming together yeah but
but outside of that I've never thought
I've never thought he was that great of
a director okay well there's one thing
for sure he is most definitely a
director he has directed films
uh Northwest standing before going we
recognize that you have since
acknowledged on Twitter that someone may
have been impersonating Miss boundary
okay good
question that you please forward us the
dmca notice you receive I I can't I
don't know why people keep saying that I
never said I got a dmca
never it seems like a lot of people and
I I understand why it's confusing but a
lot of people do not understand the
difference between a claim and like a
strike a dmca and a claim are the same
thing in a lot of people it was kind of
frustrating because it's like a dmca
would be way worse and I and I and I
want to make clear was never a dmca it
was just a claim yeah
it was just a claim to rev share
that's all it was I want to make sure I
responded and gave them the receipts he
wanted because I do want I do think they
should investigate that you know what I
mean I'm 100 with them on that
where the [__] is the
hang on I just want to make sure I did
this
let me just um
respond real fast
okay I'm just going to respond Olivia he
killed the music please
I'm gonna turn you back up so we can
hear the rest how do I kick it
if you do music in the Future Turn it
turn it way down so that I don't have to
turn
everything down and you can still play
sound bites over the mirror for sure for
sure got it we're learning we're
learning as we go it's true it's subject
receipts
damn
I mean you could just check Twitter but
that's fine I'll do your job for you
it's not like I'm busy or anything
you know what I mean yeah no I mean
seems like a lot of your clients don't
have much going on these days so I get
it if you assume that we all have a lot
of time on our hands
but I actually do but that's fine oh God
so here it is uh
I've sent it so now I i j because the
thing is
I actually greatly support you guys in
the in so far as this is a huge problem
we've identified CD Baby should be held
accountable for this [__] that is super
[__] up I will say okay
before we Slam CD Baby too hard here
um part of the submission process
because I was wondering why it still
wasn't up and I went and logged in uh
last night and it was it was in a review
stage huh
um so I've been waiting to see what gets
through on this review stage that is
interesting it says wait it says
it looks like the being inspected is
finished so we got it so you own you
just own one of my songs now for no
reason
what is the current what's that see
we're about to completely exonify
exonify exonerate exonerate your client
you can thank me for that too thank you
your releases no it's [__] innocent
okay maybe it is still in the inspection
queue so I don't know um so they clearly
do have some sort of process for
reviewing these things but whether they
just are going to Fast Track it Without
Really inspecting it or somebody may
have found a way to get around it or
something Colleen's case I don't know
maybe called you could do social
engineering yeah
yeah you guys should look into that for
sure but hey I didn't do nothing
okay
All Aboard yeah see somebody say uh
Emily Baker was claimed too but it
wasn't CD baby
um yeah we we spoke with her actually
um
from disro kid which is another one just
like CD baby
um so the fact that somebody uploaded it
to two different ones is very trollish
yeah yeah
so I believe you guys 100 you know what
I mean I'm with you I don't think she
did it so
the grooming on the other hand
jury's out highly substantiated
I have a lot more reasons to believe the
grooming allegations than not
they didn't they'd have no quibble with
the grooming allegations everything you
said about her family totally fine
100 factual
CD Baby
we demand you stop now that's right
okay thank you please don't sue me Brian
Singer
um all right we are at 40. one thing I
can say for sure about Brian Singer is
that he's a
pretty good guy
but some people would say I don't I
think so right he's a pretty good guy
he's a pred oh I see good guy
he's a predator D doodly good guy
that's a joke I I don't know anything
I genuinely don't know anything I don't
know anything this is a real photo
though actually
I know that this is a photo
that's a photograph probably that is a
photograph very possibly that's Brian
Singer I believe but I again
think that to be true Brian's like dude
you're I'm getting heat just from being
with them well I might catching Strays
yeah
come with that heat
all right let's thank our sponsors and
then we can move on with the show we
have a great show planned of course
and um y'all can stop watching now the
lawyers and stuff we're not going to
talk about it anymore
although it is fun talking about Brian
Singer that I I can't guarantee but but
I'm done talking about Colleen
I'm out
Colleen and lawyers I'm done
as long as you don't [__] you know I
mean if this this is where the story
ends then God bless
all right
I got my hands full with kavakav
fight a war on two fronts you know that
okay thank you to our sponsors
I love hexa class
me too me too I actually love love love
hexclad I I've been using the uh
products that they sent so I have a
bunch of them so you took some of the
ones home that they used and what what
products are those are you using I'm
using you know their frying pan and one
of the pots and something else and it
the the cleaning on it is [__]
unbelievable dude like just like no
scrubbing required at all and I know
like they've been that's what you always
hear about like non-stick pans but these
aren't normal non-stick and it doesn't
use teflon or any of that right [__] and
it just everything just like falls off
of it it's awesome it it's like alien
technology you know how people say
velcro's alien technology yeah it is
yeah like they've got these hexagons and
it Cooks so good it cleans so good I
mean this pan is phenomenal
and this pen is not like cheap cheap
price wise but good pans are like
hundreds of dollars and this is more
affordable
than what traditionally is thought of as
like the big big also does a lifetime
warranty so what's up now
what's up
yeah I love this this is what I use for
everything now when I cook
um
yeah let me see what to say here
um it's forever cookware
you can go find them at hexclad and you
can get a 10 off with the promo code
after Dark
wow 10 off with promo code after Dark
wow
do they not what do they don't want me
to say anything else
I mean I just I just love it
you're just surprised that the they're
yeah suggested ad copies they want me to
watch this video with Gordon Ramsay I
can talk more about it there's Gordon
Ramsay it doesn't do
piece pot s right perfectly round out
and that collection from matching the
most amazing potatoes to even potatoes I
promise you the combination of hexagonal
people you can claim me watch Alice
provide a superior productivity and a
non-stick service and ultimate
durability there's no limits it is what
you can do when you have the durability
of it's insane I mean I cannot recommend
the products enough they also have
really cool stuff they've got uh knives
I love their knives set
um
but their pans are what they're known
for yeah they got everything else they
got a whole lot of stuff it's just great
company a great product a partner too
they're really awesome to work with good
people
yeah the Damascus steel loving those I
use those for everything too
I got one of these the cutting boards
for the meats
but yeah you should check out the pans
if nothing else they're phenomenal
so um
I wish I had some with me we don't have
any in the office right maybe we took
them all home
sorry guys we actually wanted to use
them
anybody can bring one of my end though
just to show everyone off but yeah it's
all it is so good I if you're in the
market first kitchenware specifically
pans
get your Forever cookware it is that
durable that fantastic at hexa Cloud 10
off with the promo code after dark guys
hexclad.com after dark exclamation
is that really part of their URL
no
they're just excited that confused me I
I noticed that when I put it into the
description too I was like I'm pretty
sure that's gonna mess it up so anyway
go to the link in the description it's
um
once again hexclad.com after dark with
no exclamation No but we are excited we
are excited
love that pretty sure the exclamation
would
break the URL yeah it does so oh wait
there's here's talking points
uh they have a 13 piece set
perfect set to transform your kitchen
overnight because there's a full
collection of their most popular pots
pans and even a hybrid walk
the eight inch pan is perfect for eggs
you pull up the 19 inch pan for steaks
eight quart pot is there for the pasta
tonight and whether it's a quick lunch
or dinner get the whole dinner for the
entire family the 13 piece has
everything you need not to mention each
and every piece is backed by a lifetime
warranty
stop it
when choosing pans you have to pick
between the performance of stainless
steel or the durability of cast iron and
the convenience of non-stick well with
hexclad you get it all
they've got the hybrid technology that
gives you the benefit of all three and
only one pan
they have patented in laser laser etched
hexagonal steel ridges okay that's what
that is
boost your searing power while the
non-stick valleys contain its high
performing non-stick non-toxic coating
infused with diamond dust
did they say diamond does for extra
toughness
wow these are the best pants you'll ever
own
hexlight truly checks every single box
when it comes to picking your cookware
they are metal
utensils safe
that's crazy dishwasher safe they're
oven safe up to 500 Degrees they are
non-toxic and induction ready
you can cook gas and induction it even
has a stakehold handle so you can saute
with ease that's it
so how are you going to have that
special someone over for dinner with
those nasty pots and pans you're working
with no for a limited time get 10 off
with that code after dark xcloud.com
that's 10 off hexcloud.com with code
after dark Bon Appetit let's see with
hexaclad's revolutionary cookware
please support them thank you if you're
in the market
so that was about 20 minutes
we have three more we should really
crank these out I love Shopify ELO's
usually here to co-sign me on the
Shopify stuff but as far as the
platforms go for
e-commerce Shopify is the Pinnacle it is
the S tier the gold standard
from all the way from beginners all the
way up to massive billion dollar
companies they're all using Shopify and
what's great about Shopify is it allows
you to
grow from that small Etsy business all
the way up to the billion dollar company
it really does and in a sense we have
done that not billion dollars clearly
but we have grown from
tiny little uh clothing company with
three products to now we've got like 30
employees and
um you know the rest
it's so customizable
uh let's see here
uh shopify's Commerce platform
revolutionizing business we hit that
yada yada we know about that
Shopify puts you in control of every
sales channel so whether you're selling
satin sheets from shopify's in-person
POS system we're offering organic olive
oil on shopify's all-in-one e-commerce
platform you're covered
you know what's really cool when we did
a pop-up we were selling stuff and they
even gave us a point of sale system that
we could use that connects directly to
our inventory on our website how genius
is that genius
pretty cool yeah
uh once you reach your audience Shopify
has the internet's best converting
checkout to help you turn them from
browsers to buyers fantastic
um
a moment you go yeah so I don't know
about all that
[Music]
Shopify Powers 10 of all e-commerce in
the US wow Shopify is truly a global
Force powered by all birds Roth it
Powers all birds rothies Brook linen
Petty fresh and millions of other
entrepreneurs of every size across 170
countries
they've got award-winning help there to
support you on your way to success
and uh it's just so customizable with
the themes you don't have to know
anything about programming they've got
people there to help you to level up
your website
I mean me and Ila don't know anything
about programming or building websites
and we did this ourselves that's the
bottom line
obviously we have help now but at the
time we didn't need it sign up for a one
dollar per month trial period at
shopify.com after dark all lower case go
to shopify.com after dark to take your
business to the next level today
shopify.com after Dark
do you know where that one is Olivia
I think it's on ferrago
the Shopify cha-ching it's like up at
the top
hey yeah so if you guys are basically
want to help support the show and you're
looking to make an e-commerce business
it's Shopify
thank you to them
maybe we should talk a little bit then
do the other two this is like this was a
lot it's pretty heavy duty
I don't know why because sometimes like
we'll do a whole week of shows
and then we had one ad on Monday and
then four on Friday I was like can we
move it around a little bit I don't know
but that's what that's the way it is
sometimes
you know what I mean
so I'll do the the next two in a little
bit you know I want to drag this on too
much I want you guys to
to enjoy so let's do okay so you didn't
want oh no the cat pervert you wanted me
to watch this yeah
Dan told me do not watch this video
yeah I'm very sad about it who claimed
it virus from [__] viral hog
and viral hog man
I hate their business model
yeah me too anytime there's a small
video that can hear I mean this is the
video maybe you guys have seen I'm not
going to play it
what happens in it uh so the gentleman
that you're looking at is very upset
because his cat
not the person recording but the guy in
the video
uh that we're looking at yeah that guy's
cat keeps going over to the neighbor's
house because his cat
likes them more or something seems to be
the implication and he's upset about it
that's awesome and the other guy's like
what the [__] are you talking about
you're yelling at me because your cat
keeps coming into my yard dude and then
the guy starts freaking out and then he
starts calling him a cat pervert over
and over yeah he thinks he's [__]
jerking off his cat or something I don't
know well unless um unless um
I can't remember thank you Stevie Stevie
the dog guy uh yeah uh Stephen Steve
will do it unless Steve will do what
works there that lives there I don't
think I don't think he's the one
recording now I'm good yeah it's a shame
it's a very funny video and Ethan was
gonna raw react to it on the show but uh
viral hog [__] it up for all so
anytime a small video like this goes
viral they'll reach out they're so fast
they're like we'll give you a hundred
dollars for exclusive rights in
perpetuity and they're like I guess sure
on your bucks yep and then they just
terrorize the interim Style
forever man
okay H3 service dog this was pretty uh
great check this out
there's somebody out there with the H3
service dog what a good boy too you
peace and love do not pet thank you
thank you
yeah with all of the uh logo design
Brenda the show access required I'm her
family I do not separate this is awesome
I love you guys I love you both as a as
a pair
okay Ethan you're not pet oh my God I
love your dog so much you're hacking dog
I love you guys you guys are the best
ever
I love it your dog looks like such a
good boy or girl
service dogs are heroes man
[Music]
okay dot there's some doctor is drama
you must be loving this oh yeah I love
it he was so happy
so here it is
island boys making out
I got him that's Dr Ed's what oh god
what that off the screen that's the
island boys making out you guys that is
so gross I think it's so funny of them I
think they're funny yeah hold the phone
I think they're the [__] hold the
phone what is funny about it they're
just kissing each other they do it for
the time no but they're doing they're
doing incest for the vine they're
they're fine I mean nothing gets to be
funny you know that they're doing it huh
it's comical that they're doing it it is
funny to me it's like they're like these
like very cool down with like pop Trends
whatever boom incest porn
so funny because they're I think they're
doing extremely well on um only fans
they seem to have recorded a big Vibrant
Community of people who are into
twin uh identical twins you know
[Music]
so one more time I'm sorry I just wanted
to jump scare you guys I sure did
yeah I had heard about that
no the top comment is having any of you
seen gay kissing before sure that's not
what's going on
that's not the problem I'm sorry it's
funny
I gotta make it clear that's not what's
going on here all right let's talk about
Dr IDs he's a friend of this show so I'm
gonna give him all the benefit down in
the world maybe we should have the
headlines available
um yes let me see if I can get into my
email but so here's Dr Ed's video which
is a fantastic video
as you guys know the the World Health
Organization
not so much said that uh asper time
may cause cancer
but that
um
I think the media spun it that way
but Dr IDs is put he's now fully
rejected it and shows that the World
Health Organization has retracted their
statement or clarified here it is
circulating stating that aspartame may
cause cancer well as I predicted a few
weeks ago the joint expert committee on
food additives just confirmed right now
that aspartame does not cause cancer in
humans and that it is safe I'm School
you see the issue with these headlines
was that they took ir's conclusion that
aspartame was possibly carcinogenic
which was group 2B and as I've already
pointed out group 2B means that there is
inadequate or limited evidence of cancer
in humans so basically there's for dual
data in humans showing that it's
cancerous but of course media Outlets
don't know the first thing about
research so they took the phrase
possibly carcinogenic out of context and
ran
have also reaffirmed the acceptable
daily intake of aspartame which is 40
milligrams per kilogram and in reality
it would take a lot more than that
because these safety limits are
extremely conservative they are safe by
a factor of 100 and research shows that
even the most diet drink loving
Americans only reach 10 percent of the
acceptable daily intake and not to
mention this brand new systematic review
looking at dozens of studies on
aspartame and surprise surprise They
concluded that there is a lack of
evidence for it causing cancer now that
the who has once again reaffirmed the
safety of aspartame along with Europe
the FDA and every other major Health
Organization even if food and drink with
aspartame isn't your preference these
Safe products should be available for
people looking to reduce their sugar
intake and total calories so Aspartame
is safe and remember don't care about
your feelings I was dismissed
cheers this has asked for time cheers
cheers my dude cheers my dude cheers my
dude I love asper time aspartame ask for
a team shout out
so here's the here's the problem
fantastic video do you agree love were
you compelling again he's like taken
from studies and it's great and yeah I I
hear him and it sounds great I believe
it now here's what here's where it gets
intriguing yep there is a tag here that
says paid partnership and you go I don't
remember there being a sponsor in there
and then the tag is empty and you go to
the comments
and you see people are leaving the same
comment
here it is now we need conspiracy music
Olivia
[__] was bad that was so scary it was
perfect then
wait I've got something
so someone said just curious what's the
paid partnership at the bottom
Dr IDs responds and he's being
transparent I guess
or I guess he has to uh legally but he's
being transparent
um
the ABA which is the American Beverage
Association a lobbying group yep
an American lobbying group
and you know how I feel about lobbyists
is there any good lobbyists are they all
scum
well I mean yeah I'm sure there's good
luck yeah it depends on what causes
being lobbied for
you know but it's something that you
advocate for causes are good lobbyists
are not good yeah you can take issue
with the uh kind of institution the
profession of lobbying yeah but um you
know there are lobbyists that are
lobbying for positive things sure
I'm lobbying for a lobotomy for uh
anybody who doesn't drink Coke Zero
I'm sure they agree Aba
you won't talk about love you have a
credit today yeah I would love some oh
yeah oh yeah it's your day yeah no I'll
I'll take
uh you said Taco Bell party so I can
order a little bit more than usual what
does that mean are you trying to you
trying to order up for the whole week
yeah you probably shouldn't stock up
that's what he does tell me what you're
ordering before you do it I'm curious I
want the list sure what are you thinking
about how many items no I'm not going
crazy thinking maybe like 40 more than
what I usually would tell me how many
items
for crunchy three soft and uh
shumpalumpa
and how much are you going to eat of
that right now
all of it probably are like almost all
of it yeah oh for real if you can eat it
right now you get whatever you want [__]
you can get more than that okay whatever
you want good thing oh yeah of course
get what you want come on bro God damn
thanks dog Taco Bell too I'm not
ordering steaks here no no it's Taco
Bell dude yeah all right cool so but
anyway we're getting off track the ABA
approached me after seeing my dozens of
videos on sweeteners and how they're
safe
it's about time I got paid for my
efforts interpreting data
so
this doesn't discredit him on its face
of course I'm a huge fan of the IDS I
love IDs
but it does I'll say it is it is at
least a little bit of a blemish yeah
I would say if he's being compensated
financially for for these videos now now
he wasn't now I'll say this he wasn't
being paid
up until this one so those are All for
Love of the Game he he was actually how
do you know yeah if you go I sent
another comment in the Discord wait what
the [__]
yeah
how long has this been happening
okay hold on because you didn't we asked
him when he called in last if he's being
I could be misreading this but he says
he's been saying the same thing for
years
um no he's saying what I said
I feel like this may uh make people not
trust you just be super upfront about it
in the beginning of your videos that's
uh yeah I mean
anyway doctor it says you do realize
I've been saying the same thing for
years right go look at my previous
videos from 2021 on diet dreams
he's saying I've been saying the same
thing
despite not being paid back then
says litera says paid partnership and
big letters at the bottom they don't
have an account on here what more do you
want I don't know I've never done a
sponsorship on tick dogs I don't know
what the tagging process is it is a
little bizarre that it just says at
nothing I think he should I I it's one
of the things I hate on every social
media platform when they try to when
people try to hide that they're
sponsored and I'm not saying he's trying
but it should be more clear it should be
like obvious I don't like these small
tags that are hidden away at the bottom
I think it should be way more clear
well that's just my opinion
well I think as far as the consumer
is concerned that's I think that's the
way they're supposed to do it it's
supposed to be uh clearly
uh and uh uh what's the word
whatever legally this would definitely
not hold up I think
on top until that comment that I'm not
sure about
that I'm not sure about although it
doesn't say the name of the organization
that could be a problem
but so I don't know how to feel I mean
no I know how to feel I still trust him
but I I do find it interesting that this
is happening
you know
that tag is because of love
love exposed the whole thing well we did
ask him last time he was on if he was
being sponsored by them at all did we I
think we asked if he if he's been paid
by them didn't we I don't think so
didn't you I think love asks something
about like if his articles were like
paid for by Coke or something like the
research yeah right yeah yeah I think he
said he's not been financially
compensated I got annoyed a little bit
about him because he said there is no
biasy in research no funding by see and
I've had people reach out to me say the
opposite that there is quite a bit of
funding by see but now I'm curious if he
if he can argue that is there funding
biasy in promotional content online well
I know what he'll say they're just
paying me to say what I've already been
saying right but no one is paying people
to say it's bad or maybe they are but
not at the same extent dude he'll say I
mean he'll say this if something bad
comes out I'll report it regardless sure
and I think he will I believe that but
still I do think funding by C is a thing
well I was saying I hope they paid him a
lot because this is kind of
it kills the vibe a little bit Yeah does
I'm not gonna lie
but he's still my guy
so hopefully they paid him like six
figures at least for this maybe seven
life throwing millions of dollars it's
big coke it's big size I mean it's about
money if they needed a doctor to fight
for it
Coke had the money and I'm not saying he
is because I I do think he's a good guy
I do like him but I'm just saying well
let me ask you this
if you are like guys let me tell you the
truth the Earth is round everybody's
like the Earth is flat you're like no no
the Earth is round and then NASA's like
I want to sponsor you
you take the money NASA's like I want to
pay you to keep saying the Earth is
round
your thoughts
I mean the people that believe the Earth
is flat are extremely anti-nasus so that
that likely would fire them up that
would make that would not help convince
anybody right
that's the problem this is this is
poisoning the well
I I am I'm on your side but there's a
lot of people that are still skeptical
you know what you know what the problem
is though it's definitely not me right
right
everybody else
so I don't know that's kind of
interesting right I mean do you guys
agree with me on this
oh yeah I think it's a big mistake I
think on his part I think put I think
framing it as poisoning the well a
little bit
as far as his credibility is is a fair
criticism yeah yeah yeah but again I
would be clear I love this guy he is
credible he's super serious he's good at
his job he has credentials but it is an
interesting twist and and the in the
whole Dr ID Saga
I'm still I still want the because
there's a lot of people like doctors and
[__] like that that speaks against it
maybe we should hear another doctor out
or because actually because I have when
when he comes on I can prepare some
stuff why I run out of juice pretty fast
of course because I can't really but I'd
be interested in someone that has like
well the same if we can find someone or
if anybody's watching or knows someone
that is a researcher that is has
disagreeing with him doctor it's not
done that exactly like hasn't he debated
a few other researchers that are like
anti I don't think so I I just remember
the meat guys he was getting in it oh
I'm confusing doctor MD's yeah yeah the
meat carnivore boys yeah the guy that
the guy that failed on us because you
said he was a lunatic I'd be curious
specifically on I don't take it back
specifically I'm curious on the funding
biasy like I don't really care if it's
unhealthy or not I'm curious about
funding biasy so I think
again with our limited knowledge yeah
this is kind of just you can ask Chachi
BT legit I think it would have a good
insight for us the specific journals
he's talking about which are like the
gold standard yeah he's probably right
that there's
very little very little
sponsor bias or funding bias that gets
through there right
uh yeah because the whole the whole
system is built
to prevent that that being said I don't
know yeah no I mean obviously I don't
know either I would just think but let's
see what Chachi BT says I hear Dan
typing up
that's how I yeah I was were you asking
if there's any sponsor BS bias and
research remember what Journal he said
he Pub he was reading from he said it
was like the most credible in the world
well I brought up all the articles that
he mentioned has ever mentioned and all
of them are funded by similar companies
no but which Journal was the was the
research published in that I don't know
uh yeah well yeah I don't know that yes
there can be sponsor bias and research
sponsor bias occurs when the funding
source of a research study influences
the design implementation or reporting
of the research in a way that favors the
sponsor's interests or desired outcome
this place can arise from various
factors including Financial conflicts of
interest ideological bias or the
sponsor's desire to protect their
commercial or political interests well
so he says specifically the journal
vets for all this yeah right sure
oh he's available
[__] it let's get them on
if bids is here I mean he's [__] he
should be able to speak for himself you
know what I mean
it's only fair to give them a platform
we know what he's going to say though
we gotta give him a shot yeah the man
deserves a right to speak for himself
I want to ask him what Journal it was
and then you can ask Chachi BT if
there's if there's a bias in that
journal
I have nothing to argue with him today
because I'm on the same page as you it's
a blemish I suppose no no I don't expect
you to argue with them right I just
think he should if we're going to talk
about him you know if he's available
then you should call in
um
Zach needs the link someone send that
please or uh Olivia exactly the link
there we are the sound board is formerly
known as Zach
um
Peter says bias is unavoidable the
important thing is reducing bias right
by right the question is how much
reduced is the bias because big Saudi
pop is out there
and they are rich boy these are the
biggest companies in the world to be
honest yeah man you should be afraid of
big Saudi that's awesome
they're coming for all of us
so as we wait for the IDS to call in
um
remember the head let's see what else we
got oh let me think a sponsor while we
wait for Edge
PayPal honey we love you people honey I
love love love love love love love love
love love love PayPal honey can we call
the spooky music for the Adrian
I don't know what this is supposed to
mean Cameron
but oh yeah it's a poison free well it's
a pure pure water well
this is naturally occurring Spring Water
Martin approved
poison free
um thank you to PayPal honey
today's episode is sponsored by PayPal
honey the easy way to save when shopping
on your iPhone or computer I love honey
I've saved money so many times with
honey it is the magic trouser browser
plug-in that automatically browses the
internet for coupons
and applies it automatically at checkout
when you're buying stuff
the range of stuff is incredible
Electronics food Furniture clothing
everything
and I have saved me and Ila combined
have saved definitely thousands of
dollars I mean like here's one I think
it was a a cuff a table or a couch or
something without even trying We Were
Never Gonna Save this money
automatically boom 400 saved
I use honey on all my browsers because
it's utterly absurd not to do it
it's saving you money for doing
literally nothing and it's free to use
imagine you're shopping on one of your
favorite sites so when you check out the
honey button appears and all you have to
do is Click apply coupons wait a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons
you can find for that site and if honey
finds a working coupon Bob is your uncle
you'll watch the price drop magically
just like that and also exciting honey
doesn't just work on desktops now it
also works on your iPhone just activate
it on Safari on your phone and save on
the go
I love it I love it you guys use honey
right I mean who sure do
I'd be a fool not to yeah try it out I
mean it's so easy to install it's
literally just one click
um and then if you don't like it for
whatever reason you it's as easy to
uninstall it but I don't know why you
would it's just so easy
um so if you don't already have honey
you could be straight up missing out and
by getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting the show
get PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com after dark that's
joanhoney.com after dark thank you guys
please consider um
installing this free uh plugin to
support the show thank you guys
and finally as we wait for AIDS to call
in game or sub Nation alert everybody
sub Subs
I've almost killed mine look at that
sup I love gamer Subs man this beverage
what for sure be doctor is approved
it has no sweetener first of all if
you're trying to lose weight you've got
to cut the sugar hit the gamer Subs
because it's going to hit you with that
caffeine they have non-caffeine too if
that's what you're into but the flavors
are amazing it's gonna hydrate you it's
going to keep you off sugar It's Gonna
Keep You energized it tastes amazing and
they've got this big coal ass cups there
are so many flavors to choose from
how many flavors are there I mean it's
so much fun you get into you can try new
flavor so you find your products once
dozens and dozens
black cherries mine
I still got to try the Pina Colada one
that sounds really good
and then you're doing the mango Dan is
that you always do
uh no I always do the blue Razz oh yeah
blue Razz yeah anyone else hitting it oh
damn a b a b o b
what flavor is that one I won't say it
I'm doing an ad here
oh dragon fruit passion fruit fashion is
that a new one
oh it's the first time I tried it but I
really like it
gamer sub Goes Down Easy
goes down nice and easy don't worry it's
a B has a tight little throat he has a
tight little throat he has a clinical
yeah this is an AB issue
the same way but I love it and and love
you are a gamer sup you've transformed
right he's an Aficionado now I've tried
all of the powder Bay pretty much all of
the Power powder based um kind of energy
drinks by far the best thank you uh one
of the main things I like with this is
that the powder dissolves fully you will
not have to shake multiple times uh with
competitors you're gonna have to shake
every time you take a drink really yeah
interesting that's a huge Advantage yeah
it is yes I haven't I haven't drank any
of that other lead-filled crap right
I stick with gamer Subs yeah but this
blends perfectly and it stays Blended
like for multiple hours it's great holy
smoke yeah okay I didn't even realize it
was on that level yep well thank you
love go to gamersups.gg and use code H3
you get free shipping on a free sample
oh they're doing this guys this is the
best
next 48 hours
use a code H3 and you get a free sample
use code H3 to get free shipping on a
free sample that means you don't have to
spend you don't even have to spend any
money
you literally go to the website type
code H3 and they send you a free sample
you don't even have to pay for shipping
do you understand what I'm saying free
means free try it see if you love it
this was dragon fruit punch by the way
really good nice and
in the near future here we will have our
own flavor very excited about that yes
indeed
yeah I hope it yeah I think it came out
really good I'm excited yeah if you
missed the 48 hour window you can still
use code H3 a checkup for 10 off but
guys if you wanted to try it Now's the
Time go to gamersups.gg use code H3 and
get free shipping and a free sample for
the next 48 hours thank you thank you to
gamer Subs please consider supporting
one of our sponsors thank you peace and
love
we did it out through all four
um I see people spamming Emily oh Jesus
did Emily a baker say something about
this or is that just unrelated what does
Emily mean
uh let me check I'm not sure what it
what was the comment that you saw
I just I saw a few people typing Emily I
I don't know yeah I think she might have
been claimed too no yeah she she was
claiming we covered it earlier
yeah sorry guys I usually don't like to
do four ads I know it's like a lot
but uh I don't know why they they do it
like that
but I hope you guys don't mind uh
occasionally having to listen to me do
that
here's Emily Baker she just posted this
this morning okay this is fresh update
Colleen Ballinger's lawyer responded by
saying neither are this is the same
thing yeah
yeah
here's her original one from five hours
ago sometime overnight and interest rate
recordings
for Colleen Ballinger copyright claimed
my members only live stream
for Revenue sharing who else has been
claimed so
she says has my claim been released yet
yes some ifis that is not them someone
is playing a dangerous game right now
yeah
I think someone actually went to jail
for this recently really like legit yeah
geez I mean it is uh
theft I mean you're literally stealing
some broad money yeah
broad theft
yeah not smart not anywhere as close to
bad as what uh Brian singers uh alleged
of doing but still bad
right
uh I have uh it's in the waiting room
all right let's talk to our boy listen
to Love's order let's see one creamy
Chipotle crispy chicken taco one avocado
ranch crispy chicken taco two crunchy
Taco Supremes A Chalupa Supreme and a
Crunchwrap Supreme all without cheese
and tomato that's fine hell yeah
let's get after it let's go dude
somebody here can order for us oh
because I know we're running light yeah
we'll we'll get it done I'm I can get
something too right
it's not cam can I have one oh no yeah
of course what are you guys talking
about it's a party it's a party dude
what do you want I don't know
I got the Nacho Bell Grande and it kind
of grossed me out last time
you need you need the creamy Chipotle
crispy chicken taco wait you tried that
last time no it was like that yeah I
don't like the soft tacos though oh [__]
you probably sub hard shell
avocado ranch crispy chicken taco this
is out of control man it's good dude
I like it
just get me like two uh Taco Supremes
let's keep it light let's keep it Breezy
yeah
two tacos let's keep it light two tacos
Supreme that's what that's right I guess
my Taco Bell standards that is like that
is very long taco supreme
calories and it is so light bro if
there's a lot now oh wait yeah for sure
in my mind I was thinking burrito
supreme two burrito Supremes that would
be a lot heavier apparently it's 190
calories and one taco supreme oh that's
great I could breathe in a taco supreme
yeah yeah I mean so I I I my mind subbed
burrito for taco I was thinking
something bigger so if I have two of
those dirty dudes that's four almost 400
calories dirty dudes
that's not going to be good for my quota
I'll be I'll tell you that for sure
forget about it maybe I'll skip me you
know what I might I might get nothing
wow
I might get nothing wow maybe one maybe
one taco supreme
that's a dainty little twinkle little
snack with extra meat
extra meat
no we're not doing anything like that
[__] one taco supreme all right
that's me
let's go
let's [__] do this let's go
all right let's talk to IDs
okay one moment please
I will
let him into
the room
it's all that is all that it's all that
you guys remember that it's all that
theme song
with Coolio you talking about the Coolio
yeah yeah yeah but you say oh wait no
that's the Keenan that's the Keenan kill
show
uh it's all that Dr Ed's is in the house
can you hear me
seems like he's still trying to um
working on it yeah he's trying to get in
there
so as he tries to set that up I'll
continue it's all that it's all that
uh
your your audio is uh extremely
distorted it's coming through just
barely but there is um some sort of
distortion going on he's on it okay
so
let's see what else we got here today so
after this we definitely got to get into
the Dan chat uh the Chan the Dan
Chandler
we got to oh there's a new James Charles
article this is so good
we'll do Dan Schiller first
but uh Cosmic Cosmopolitan did a puff
piece
on James Charles
what that is so true let me guess who's
James Charles lawyer
nope
I don't know who's his lawyer is how
would I know that
yeah we got a video to watch while we
wait
[Music]
oh not poor poor fousey
wait this music is yeah
which means we can't listen to it that's
a bummer
where's the ones who've been getting
trolled on his live streams lately
worthless
yeah he's been doing a IRL streams yeah
and he has does this thing where I guess
if people donate
he has a voice read the donation out
loud no matter where he is and we've
seen this before uh this is a streamer
IRL streamer technique to get donations
but the way they're hitting fousey with
these is bro does he have 11 or 10 000
Subs that's really good
that's fake
oh it's fake he manually updates it and
just puts a random numbers wait does he
do that as a joke no no he does that to
fake people out no he thinks he looks
cool
no but he does that with the intention
to deceive people right yeah he want to
look rich I think what yeah it's super
weird it increases by like a thousand to
two thousand per day
what yeah I've never heard of that
but cam found it without the music
who sees a force in nature man
also you know what I say about Bass Pro
Shop hat wears
only the best
okay I think it's one sec
yo I'm believing take it off me I'm
leaving I'm leaving
you know something I discovered uh at
this stage in my life it's not cool to
mess with people's phobias like when
someone tells you like I'm deathly
afraid of like cockroaches or something
like it's not funny to
you know throw cockroaches at him
because it it traumatizes them in a way
that you don't really understand
you know what I mean like it causes them
psychic pain
uh so
you know I'm out on so I don't think
this is cool but it is funny
because it's fousey
and he has 10 000 Subs so
congratulations to him that's really
incredible I was impressed by that love
all right doctor it's thank you for
joining us I don't waste too much of
your time here
um
so there is a little bit of a we have a
little bit of some hard questions for
you IDs oh yeah yeah of course I'm ready
okay now now everybody's talking Dr IDs
is now sponsored by the ABA is that
correct
it's well yes first of all it's true but
it's a short term three-month contract
that ends probably
in about a month and a half and the
reason they approached me
is because they've seen the dozens of
videos I've done on artificial
sweeteners
stating the evidence showing they're
safe and they knew that The Who and I
Arc were going to convene during the
summer
so they wanted you know medical
professionals Healthcare professionals
who understand the data to basically
remind people that the data does show
that Aspartame is safe and that is what
it does show and actually the who
research arm called jekfa which are the
food additives research arm they just
concluded that it's safe so you know
that's what everyone expected
so so what is the requirements on you as
part of the sponsorship deal what do
they require of you
if you're so there's no disgusting you
don't have to yeah yeah it's just a
number of videos I think two a month for
a couple of months
um and basically it's pretty open
there's no requirements it's just they
like the style of my videos
um you know they like how I interpret
the data and they are they saying
specifically do two videos about
artificial sweeteners that are
um that with the focus on them being
safe for consumption
so the whole summer campaign that
running is to show the artificial
sweeteners are safe in particular
um aspartame so they've so they launched
a new website called Safety of
aspartame.com
and as you can see there it lays out all
of the evidence all of the individual
research studies they go through over a
hundred of them they go through all of
the health institutes from across the
world the European Food Safety Authority
Jack fur
um the you know FDA Australian New
Zealand all of the major health
institutes from across the world right
at all of their statements showing that
it's safe so basically they're running a
campaign because they know that some of
these ridiculous headlines are going to
come out and cause Mass confusion
amongst people right so they basically
said look you've done a really good job
so far of reiterating the science so we
want you to continue doing that and I
was like
right you're going to pay me to repeat
what I've been saying for years that's
fantastic are you are you afraid that
the perception of it will tarnish your
credibility even the perception of being
paid by a a lobbying group
sure it could to those who are
non-critical thinkers sure people that
love conspiracies well I don't think
that's fair to wipe everybody
well
well I think it's logical to to at this
point to assume hey you know if this
guy's being paid by a lobbying group I
don't think you have to be a
non-critical thinker to say well that
that that warrants a second thought
well if you're not aware that I've been
saying this for years yeah and then yes
but anyone who knows my content they've
seen the 15 20 videos prior to me being
sponsored anyway right so there's
there's evidence of years backlog of
publicly viewed videos where I say the
exact same thing my stance hasn't
changed at all if my stance did change
and I all of a sudden let's say I was
paid by um you know some kind of sugar
manufacturer or something and they
wanted me to say look we want you to say
that artificial sweeteners are harmful
so more people come back towards the
full sugar drinks yeah if I own
if I saw another doctor saying that I
would be like yeah it's more it's more
it's not as of it's not as obvious as
that it's a little more subtle right
um
but I you know I I like you said you've
been doing this for a long time so your
message hasn't changed right but I do
think I'm of my fear is that there are
people
um like love not true but he is still
skeptical and he is critical he does
critically think
uh that will look at this and say
um I knew it there is something going on
here with this guy
sure and you would have it you would
have a case if I was going against the
scientific consensus but actually you
look at every major Health Institute
from across the world independent or
otherwise they all have my stance
if you're going to be skeptical of me
then you need to provide an argument
which nullifies all of the leading
Health experts from across the world in
all different countries not America I'm
not even talking about the FDA I'm
talking about Europe Australia New
Zealand the UK all the other major
health countries what are you drinking
there I noticed you switched it up you
got red drink now we run out of yellow
oh no summer fruits cranberry now summer
fruits cranberry everybody
yeah yeah what's the name of the
organization or there's a journal you
said is like soup the most credible that
doesn't have bias which one was that
there's well there's a lot of them but
one of the leading examples is the
Journal of the American Medical
Association okay and the New England
Journal of Medicine that's a UK
do they have no bias so second so your
claim is that these journals have no
bias no no no no no no no there's no
research paper in the world that can
ever have no bias even if it's not
funded a researcher can always have an
internal bias where you know they might
be inclined to
you know maybe hide maybe run a number
of statistical tests that might be
favorable for them or design the trial
that might be favorable favorable for
them no one can ever say there's no bias
okay what I'm saying is
the methodology and the stipulations
these prestigious journals have in place
makes it very hard for these things to
get through so even if a researcher
tries really hard to push something
through there's so many steps before
that you have to pre-register the study
you have to tell them how you're going
to conduct the study you have to have an
independent statistician you have to
have an independent data Handler it then
has to be peer reviewed by colleagues
who have nothing to do with you right
and believe me colleagues in the
research space they can quickly see very
easily if someone's trying to manipulate
something so there's loads of barriers
in place so just for those listening
here here's an excerpt the Journal of
the American Medical Association Jammer
strives to maintain objectivity and
avoid bias in its Publications however
it is important to recognize that buys
still exist and any scientific journal
bias can arise from various sources such
as authors reviewers editors and even
funding sources but to mitigate
potential bias Jama follows rigorous
peer review process where experts in the
field evaluate the scientific Merit and
validity of submitted articles the
process helps to identify and dress any
potential bias or method methodological
flaws in the research
so you know so can I ask a follow-up
question oh absolutely
um you know biasing in like uh research
they have very firm kind of
anti-measures right I'm curious is there
I'm assuming there's not as hard
measures on like public information like
uh what kind of ads they're funding and
stuff like that
um you mean uh non-academic media yeah
like like your I guess yeah like funding
outside like of promotion of research
like your Tick Tock for example do you
think there's yeah
or could be oh yeah yeah that can be
biased on any kind of Outlet headlines
media advertisements influences doctors
yeah okay well his his video is not peer
reviewed if that's what you're at that's
that's my point yeah yeah it's just a
tick tock video Yeah well for example
yeah go ahead
it's not peer-reviewed but what I'm
saying has been paired sure right yeah
that's that's the point right all right
is I just want to check in on that was
an interesting development in the story
arc of Dr Ed's he's now on the payroll
of big soda
yeah not for much longer but it's going
to end soon but yeah they better keep
paying you though otherwise your
opinions might change you know what I
mean
switching the water here pretty soon
if the data if the data changes which is
pretty pretty damn hard it could have 40
years worth of data but let's say in 20
years time if I'm still on social media
um if you know a dozen or two dozen
research studies come out suggesting
that a specific type of sweetener causes
harm then of course I'll update my
stance until that people have accused
you of poisoning the world well I'm here
to say sugar-free and poison free well
of doctor and to join a fine Coke Zero
well I'm here drinking a Coke Zero so
obviously I'm riding with you still
well you'll be riding with every major
Health Institute across the world so
that's it and that's who I ride with
that's my that's my crew
that's me too
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna say anything
that isn't the scientific consensus
there it is unlike these carnivore flops
all right
um Dr IDs thanks again for the call in
short notice I always appreciate it
of course my friend hope everyone's well
and I'm glad you're getting paid what
are we talking six figures or less
I'm not comfortable saying okay
it's it's a substantial amount which you
know dwarfs what UK doctors are paid
which is which is great so good then you
know what I mean [__] yeah why not well
I mean I mean you know UK doctors are
only paid like 14 pound an hour so huh
how did wait you can't doctors don't
make money
we don't make money at all because UK
dollars are poor
thousands of doctors are striking right
now
wait where but how do they afford to go
to medical school and all that [__] they
take loans and then they pay back at 14
pounds an hour
well like well like 10 gets taken out of
the salary every month so actually a lot
of doctors who are newly qualified
they'll be taking home something like
eighteen hundred pounds a month wait
wait 48 48 hours
yeah a week
UK doctors make nothing we make nothing
here what
that's part I just saw it's so the
opposite of here in America yeah yeah of
course yeah well that's doctors are like
Elite [__] uh you know
bourgeoisie right yeah yeah the maximum
even after 20 years of training becoming
a top consultant becoming you know
spending all of your life rotating
around different hospitals becoming a
Super specialist you'll only be on like
eighty thousand ninety thousand
that's when you're 50 years old that's
pretty stunning I'll say a lot of people
it's debated if doctors should get paid
as much as they do here in America but
actually one thing that I don't think
people talk about which is really in
favor of paying doctors a lot
is that
they are less
um
inclined to pursue other Revenue options
that might uh compromise them or because
there's a lot of ways that doctors can
make money outside the practice to
endure stuff or talk about this and that
and if they're if they're millionaires
just by their profession they're not
going to be working with
um
with other companies you know what I
mean yeah that's true and also paying
them fairly adequately prevents them
from leaving you know the issue we have
here in the UK
one in three doctors are planning to
leave
the NHS what the [__] we have we have 60
000 or more than something like 60 000
job vacancies and we're really
struggling wow that's mind-blowing yeah
it's pretty bad
that is interesting because we uh the
Healthcare System here gets so much [__]
but
I mean I think it's good that doctors
are well compensated it prevents it's
important it's such an such an important
uh profession
yeah yeah well you need to tell that to
um you know Rishi the guy leading the UK
right now
um are there private doctors that that
are like compensated really well yeah
private doctors they earn significantly
more but
the issue is you have to be part of the
NHS service before you become privatized
and also you need to still have your
foot in the door of the NHS because
they're the ones you know the GMC is the
people that run your license they
monitor your license
so they they don't make it easy like if
I wanted to go into private practice I
can't because I need to you know go
through a certain number of steps I need
to do a certain number of years
um so they almost try to like
I am a surgeon sorry about that doctor
very unprofessional Olivia I'm so sorry
I am I am
I got it again but seriously like uh
many people are leaving I've got so many
friends who've gone to Australia believe
that that's that's I'm sorry to hear
that I I always assumed that you were
just out there doing really well by your
professional loan that's that's horrible
my friend we make nothing pennies well
good get that money and you know what I
mean let's drink that coke get that
money do that coke my my my you know my
rationale is if I can get paid to carry
on educating based on the strongest data
believe me I'm gonna get paid yeah I've
spent thousands I spend thousands of
hours making free content it's about
time someone bloody paid me absolutely
let's [__] go I'm with you Dr Ed's
for Dr IDs for Aba
laughs
all right thank you for calling very
much appreciate it thanks Ethan thanks a
lot thank you love you
thank you
that's did you guys know that that kind
of blew my mind yeah seems scary
uh about the their compensation yeah no
I you know get that back doctor it's uh
I'm not gonna hate
I mean in the US we still got to pay
back you know it's not that bad of
course but student loans it is a lot
each year coming out of our salary once
we start making money
we I believe in this are you still
paying back loans what the [__]
how much you owe can I ask 60 000. damn
bro and for how long were you in there
uh I was in there for a while like
several years I switched from you were
all to Medicine you were in several
years and now you're working here
thank you
[__]
probably a smart decision honestly yeah
sixty thousand all right we'll get that
down we're gonna get that down thank you
you've been a huge help so far thank you
yeah uh Joe Biden uh might be getting
that down I actually saw some news about
that this morning
they're trying a different approach to
the student debt cancellation I was like
go get them Joe
uh yeah credit where credit's due I like
that he's not just completely backing
down somebody wrote the average NHS
salary is 190 000 per year that does not
that is that doesn't conform with what I
was I just looked it up and uh the
median UK doctor salary is 58. it's 59
000 pounds per year which the pound is
really fell off so pound
brexit has really been wonders for
their currency
a thousand dollars I mean listen it's
not terrible but it's also not amazing
and I know England is also a very
expensive place to live
um I don't know
I mean London's one of the most
expensive places
yeah nurses make more than that in
America
that's crazy that seems really low for
what they do
someone said they're in 500 000 debt for
dental school [__] Pearl but Dentists
get paid so if you if you can last all
the way through
you know what I mean
just look at Jimmy
you could become Jimmy Lee you could be
the next Jimmy Lee and if that's not
encouraging I don't know what is all
right different flavors let's get to um
let's get to the big moment at hand
we've all been waiting
it's the dantler let's go let's go
do we have a sting or anything or
uh no but we have a fancy graphic that
uh cam made
a second and I found this music pretty
quickly yeah uh shout out thank you yeah
oh this is fantastic
so Dan has been complaining about his
scorpion chair which I spent big money
on okay yeah
I feel like I've always been very
gracious about this chair yeah well
not So Much Anymore
uh Dan has uh snow but we all our hearts
go out to Dan he's suffering I am kind
of suffering
you've long fat past the expectations
for enjoying that chair yes I would
think so if you think she should suffer
no
so I think it's we all agree it's time
for Dan to get a new chair
but what chair is good enough to uh
secede
succeed succeed
to depose
the Scorpion chair okay
so fans have submitted the greatest
options available from absurd to
executive and everything in between and
Dan as our Bachelor
as our Bachelor back chiller
is going we're going to be doing a
bracket here of
um a competition to find out who is
going to be our match our loving match
for Dan
and no matter what it is we'll buy we'll
make we'll commission we'll do whatever
it takes to get break this chair into a
reality and I should say I have done my
damnedest to avoid spoilers on this uh I
did pull up the graphic just a moment
ago so I got a little glimpse of uh some
of them oh you haven't seen these I've
I've tried to I I figured it would be
more fun if I was seeing them so you're
gonna have to choose one of these that's
the idea right there's one two three
four five six seven eight so you have 16
I think 16 options I'm looking at it
some of them look very nice
it's it's on this screen right here I am
trying not to uh look at it yet I mean I
don't think it yeah okay and then so the
rules as we established would be
um
it's up to you but like don't the
audience get to vote
a little bit
no I I said we can do audience votes
just to get their uh input but um I
don't want to say that I will commit to
what the audience picks because uh they
like to troll me they would obviously
pick the worst one I think they want the
best for you we love Dan I don't know
I don't know I think I think what we
should do is
the audience needs some power in this
Dan
you know what I mean it just needs to be
uh I I don't know no I disagree
I disagree that you disagree
let's do something like I just put
disagree because I was between disagree
and agree you know how during America's
Got Talent they have like the golden
button
the golden buzzer absolutely the golden
buzzer puts you automatically through to
the finale oh interesting
so maybe what we can do is
um
each one it's not a vote if you like it
it's golden buzzer this yes or no
[Music]
and if that yes gets 70 or more you have
to own that chair forever
as bad of roll yeah I don't uh no I
don't want to agree to that all right
let's get the idea is that we get a
chair that isn't going to physically
hurt me let's get started the first
chair
of the 16 filing finalists and
congratulations to everybody who
proposed these there's also a quick
gallery of honorable honorable mentions
too if you want to just oh we could take
a look through that really fast oh yes
let's please so here is a um
a video of the honorable mentions and
thank you to everybody who submitted
them these are all fantastic
I thought this would be really good for
you
you think you could run the show on this
thing but no have you ever done one of
those I actually have no it's very
disoriented probably yes I think you I
think we found your new chair
in other words
hold my hand
here's another uh
honorable mention
is this free music guys no I don't think
so that's kind of perfect
so obviously okay that rules though why
is this one he's got a radar too even at
the top oh why is this one not a
not an option is that an honorable
mention um well that makes me excited
for the ones that are because we can I
guess you can you can get it in there I
think we have really good ones though
there's something about that sofa chair
all right so that all being said
let's get into the competition here
first we have submitted by Jay Blanda we
need we need some kind of music I think
to set the scene here's music you can
turn it up a little bit higher steel
case seat
okay so this is just a straight up real
suggestion for you oh wow so this is the
steel case
uh line
of leap chairs this is the leap
okay maybe you'll be leaping into
comfort with your new chair high
performance seating high performance 219
reviews what does that mean high
performance seating there's nothing
really high performance about sitting
yeah what am I performing I want to load
this one frankly yeah are we not
performing all the time every day
oh we are energy I mean that's true I
mean if we really want to talk about it
[Music]
hey nice
beautiful but this looks like a
fantastic option for dance okay so as an
executive and deserves an executive
chair yeah uh okay this is this is
interesting I didn't know that there
would be any just like normal up there
are several okay now this one is of
course coming in at 1000 to 2 600.
you'll be expected to get the bare
minimum of course
really design on the design cut no I'm
kidding you can get whatever you want
I'm expecting you get the plastic wheels
and the uh one with the CO2 cartridge
shoots up to your house go down too fast
oh no but okay that looks pretty good
huh I mean yeah uh it's the first one so
I don't have anything to compare it
against but that looks like a very nice
chair all right so up against we have
the plush office chair by just
peachy99 and let's see if this is just
peachy or not
here it is
oh my goodness gracious whoa what get a
load of this thing what is happening
here Dan's new chair needs to be over
the top comfy but practical going from
hard sharp scorpion through this plush
comfortable computer chair
that looks what is reticle wait what is
this
I mean that one kind of rules right
oh [__] that's like a Billionaire's
chair imported black cowhide leather oh
I don't maybe they have a um support for
their product I'm sorry I mean if they
do that would be great it has 10 wheels
bro it has offloads I mean it looks
incredible all Wheels all Road it has a
massage function
and a foot rest function oh
but I need to know what the [__] is this
like what's the price they didn't where
do I I have a feeling this is absurdly
expensive
where what is uh well what is it called
there's a link oh there's a link okay oh
there is thank you that chair looks like
you need to be drinking whiskey I have
like every time you sit in it oh my see
these chairs they surprise you obviously
two thousand not that bad 2 300 is
expensive well it's a lot for a chair
but I was expecting it to be way worse
so this is interesting the quilly
Massage office chair
in there
maybe you can compromise
I mean you probably have leather in your
car
I don't no oh you probably have leather
in your house somewhere I mean I'm sure
I do I just try to not go out of my
I'm not that hardcore about it but I try
not to okay well you're after you know
what I mean tough decision this is the
first bracket again that we have um I
love that one see a beautiful chair more
let's say subtle more understated yeah
yeah and here we have the plush office
chair a a seat
suited for a king 10 wheels off-road
all-wheel drive
prostate massager
um love can you do me a favor just
because I'm juggling a lot can you be
putting up the polls for these sure
thank you
this is actually a good lineup because
these are both really good options
now I mean my heart my heart says uh
maybe I should say my brain says this
one
the uh
the leather one but my my heart tells me
I've got to go with the other one and is
it the leather that's turning you off
that's the only problem if I could get
it with pleather or whatever that that's
that's obviously the winner that's a
shame because that one is way funnier
looking because the the other one is so
like this is a yeah I'm assuming that
this is like our our one normal entry so
we'll see how far it actually gets
versus all of like the insane ones all
right well apologies to just peachy uh
it's a fantastic suggestion it really
was it really was
but um I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have
to pick okay well there it is
uh peace and love to the cows Dan is
riding with you my friends I love the
cows moose
man [__] them cows you're gonna be in
this chair for a long time Dan I want
you to really think about this
really think about it well there's gonna
there's lots of other options right I'm
with AV it's like this might be
this might be the one that you let get
away when you end up on an uncomfortable
chair I'll be like thank the cows
I will you could be reclining you could
have your feet up you get your prostate
and your back pain massage I'll get you
a little tube that no I'm not gonna say
that joke
laughs
all right he's made his choice uh yeah I
I'm sorry I'm sorry I can't I can't
compromise on that one uh did the people
vote did we set up a poll they're
currently voting
what'd you say yeah it's up they're
voting right now let's see I'm curious
what the people think now obviously I
think people are going to sympathize
with your oh yeah every everyone's
saying people want the fancy massage
chair dude
the people they they agree because that
chair really is something man I mean
look at that I mean could we get it
reupholstered
maybe we can find a old one used one
info
um
in stock one to two business days holy
[__] oh that's quick one to two you
could have this item by next week you
want to read some details about it I
don't I don't I don't want any more
Temptation I've made my choice okay I'm
gonna sit in it
we're moving on poor choices sorry
everybody
all right up next all right what do we
got next the next mashup is pink gaming
chair uh-huh submitted by Nick lib let's
take a look
this is the cute pink gaming chair to go
with your cute pink aesthetic
go for the whole e-girl thing
interesting that is kind of awesome the
the cat paw oh with the cat paw wait
hold on you guys are customizing his
whole damn
the whole setup that is kind of awesome
to be honest
whoa
okay don't hate it it's very funny okay
but at the end of the day though it's
just a standard one of those like uh
what a DX racer or gaming chairs
essentially for sure I mean I've sat in
those those are okay but I think we need
to go something a little nicer than that
but you've stuck for too long yeah but
what's it up against
the rich Lux chair supported by pale ad
interesting the rich luxury this is the
rich Luxe share shout out to the king
oh nice yeah that one is really
important you'll no longer have to be uh
jealous of him one bro this Throne is
like really important this is on this is
from an Etsy artist oh certainly custom
made thirteen hundred dollars important
and um
it is called the pink Throne it is maybe
the prettiest thing I've ever seen in my
life I'll just say it oh and is it
really it is really his chair oh that is
everything dude that's really special
and I think that's really really awesome
if you get that you've got to get the
crown and the makeup and everything then
oh yeah Dan Lux 10 Lux poor Lux I'll be
poor Lux give me Ridge Lux
um um I think that that is I I'll be
honest I don't think that that's gonna
make it to the end because I imagine
that isn't that comfortable to sit in
for a long period of time it's a throne
but is that is funny enough of an idea
that I think it can carry forward in the
competition so there we go looks like
the audience agrees so yeah I liked it I
like the rich Lux chair quite a bit that
is that is oh I just got a glimpse of
them okay I can't wait for this next
round all right the next bracket we have
the Akira chair permitted by lizard
crowbar
take a look Akira of course the classic
manga anime series
uh this is a custom design
we have here a Akira style motorcycle
with a monitor we'll take a look I mean
you know when it says Dannon on the side
instead of Canon that's [__] that's
sick I love this movie
um and I love the whole cyberpunk
motorcycle thing it's gonna cost me a
fortune you guys that is absurdly cool
now that said
on a comfort level
this will probably suck at least as much
as the Scorpion logistically also with
the tube shape is going to be tough we
can make it work yeah I mean
yeah I guess
I was gonna say it's probably not that
much longer than scorpion chair but I
think it actually would be it would be
yeah it'd be like significantly longer I
mean this is a [__] sick idea but
well you have to choose one the next one
all right yes
this of course is one that I um
this is a chair that I have experienced
with this is the chair that was featured
in the uh sperm collection room oh wow
with the um you know protective sheet
there okay I don't think we need to do a
poll for this one I I ain't sitting in
uh in Ethan's goo no and just so you
know I would volunteer to to uh I'm sure
thank you that's right on a regular
basis thank you oh it's a refresh the
field that's cool
um we're gonna move on with uh uh is it
is that the character
Canada I don't know yeah Canada right
well congratulations to lizard crowbar
for that one up next is the care bro
seat by extension hat care bro
let's take a look three bro the audience
is voting for the sperm Champion boy but
uh well I'm gonna have to reject y'all
that is kind of Epic it's very funny
I'm voting sperm chair
so this is the what is this sorry it's
uh whoa X-Men
cerebro oh like the helmet one yo do we
have the technology to make so that you
can control it with your mind yet
uh uh I could get a Elon Musk chip put
in right isn't that I think it just got
cleared that's FDA approved oh yeah
let's go
um this is very cool it looks so this is
like a custom design yeah like somebody
made this in blender or something it
looks like it uh very cool I like the
amount of monitors I like the
thoughtfulness of uh leaving a nice Gap
like it doesn't have this bar that the
Scorpion chair has which is very um
obstructing for the camera shot
um
this is cool this is a cool design now
that said this doesn't actually exist
yeah this would be like a fully
fabricated thing which we'll do we'll do
that and
by that same token is it even
structurally sound like you can make
this in blender but that's a lot of
weight well subject to to uh Engineers I
know what you could do that oh Ian
saying it's a gallery there's other
photos oh [__] click next at the top
there oh wow we got a whole blueprint
the rec line of sight to podcast hosts I
know to see I noticed that yeah six
times 27 inch displays RGB infinity
mirror along inside face you have a beer
and some rope lights like that custom
helmet for improved Focus oh it oh I
didn't even realize
yeah it's actually the cerebral dude
this is super cool are you gonna be
comfortable putting your head in a
little device well I would imagine I
wouldn't have to use it I mean I sort of
do already I wear headphones right it's
permanent it's a permanent fixture yeah
yeah yeah
you can't move it
yeah that seems like that would get a
little old a comfortable desk chair
cable path that what I noticed that very
clever yeah uh moving to the next slide
we've got here is all the WoW
measurements they've they've they've
really thought this out this is
extremely cool whoever uh actually put
all this work this is by extension hat
2750 right well let's see who it's up
against uh I see who it's up against and
I'm gonna tell you I think this one is
definitely moving on because hold on
Ronald McDonald's don't judge a book by
its cover
this is um submitted by Wes does stuff
and here is an iconic chair
one that we all know and love the sweet
the lovely the innocent neighborly
Ronald McDonald the clown I'm not gonna
lie that'd be so [__] funny for that
to just be my chair all the time every
time it cuts to my shot we actually got
Ronald around my shoulder we actually
found this
um
next to a park for kids Ronald was
sitting by the place watching McDonald's
we sniped it oh no
so Dan this I don't know why you're
hating this is Iconic
uh yeah it's just um uh it is Iconic but
the uh the other one is just the fupa
Trooper puts so much effort into that
but like
ah that would be so good so you're
voting for The I'm sorry the cerebro is
too cool uh to even meme about the
McDonald's one well the people are
agreeing it's close frankly but the
cerebro is winning so congratulations
okay so we're oops looking good coming
along here yeah we're halfway through
the first round here all right so up
next we have gamer bed
the Japanese gamer bed okay so uh it's
the gamers final form now this is built
so that you can sleep where you play I
could just lay down what it does Dan is
it minimizes movement to maximize
gameplay time yeah that's sick uh it's
basically a hospital bed
with a [__] desk attached and as you
can see it comes with a cover that it's
provided
is that actually a promo image like how
does that comfortable like you just
there's no back you're just like sitting
up awkwardly on the bed well they assume
sleep is going to be minimal
so it's really just there for
convenience you got your Sodis and your
chips right and so you can just
crap
you know
of course that's how you you're living
on chips and soda if you this is a real
product they're actually yeah somebody
made this yeah it's Japan and they you
know what I mean this is crazy oh you
can hold your cell phone above your head
while you're falling asleep dude do they
have they have like Lube
what is that down at the yeah it could
be Lube
there's a tissue receptacle and uh so
you can easy grab so you don't have to
get up
oh
first I was actually kind of hot on this
uh thinking about being able to lay down
while we do the show that sounds kind of
cool
I don't know it seems it seems like it
wouldn't actually be very uh
comfortable yeah actually you have to
sleep with your knees up yeah like
it's just not enough space
all right up against the gamer bed is
the massage chair submitted by one
substance oh okay three nine five here
it is what in the [__] and [__] tits is
this whoa
so cozy that looks so cozy that looks
like a cockpit seat to like a
Starfighter or something can I get a
link to this
to the actual uh yeah I don't know I
think I've I think I've seen actually
I've sat in one of these I have aren't
they supposed to be airport yeah frankly
no no yeah they have these on display I
was also at a friend's house with an
extremely wealthy parent and he had one
of these there it's really not that good
I actually have a funny story about that
they have these at the airport as Olivia
pointed out I sat down in it on the way
here
and it started beeping because it didn't
want me to sit in it until I paid so
it's like you have to pay and like
embarrass the [__] out of me so I had to
like leave it and walk away you didn't
pay so yeah these chairs they're um
embarrassing they embarrass you yeah
it's like purpose this guy didn't pay
anything fair yeah here it is or
something similar chairs are
inconsiderate this is the human touch
Novo XT massage chair
changes the game it says
uh let's get to the for it they have a
concierge service
um what's that mean no no they'll bring
you stuff
that's just part of when you buy the
chair you kind of get like an assistant
yeah
control panel foot calf massager I I
would be into this one but if it weren't
for you telling me you've sat in one it
wasn't that comfortable
well
I I'm just being honest I'm being honest
maybe maybe people have different
experiences but I was not impressed I
was not impressed okay where's the price
where's the uh
uh good question maybe it's a special
order only
what the hell because normally these are
like people
put these in malls 10K yeah 10K yeah
that's fine I can we can do that here
here's the exact one here it is so you
got all kinds of color options
you know black black also black also
black another black gray green oh I kind
of like the cream
um on sale from fifteen thousand all
right well time I'm not completely sold
on this idea but I will say I would
definitely prefer this over the bed we
can also get it on a payment plan 167 a
month so that's nice that seems
reasonable over the course of the next
20 years we'll pay that off
uh yeah I'm gonna go ahead and have to
say the massage chair between these two
uh because the gamer bed is just a
little too that's it's a little too
smelly yeah okay um
big news oh boy
what happened
a fan
a very kind what happened sent me this
apparently going back to round one they
do have a fake leather option oh this is
not the same chair though just to be
clear it's not nice but it's not as
luxurious look at it
huh
does it well okay
I thought it was the same one the image
this the image it shows in the thumbnail
is different this is the same company
though is it not yeah
like how do why does it look so cool
here
hmm microfiber leather yeah so
apparently that is a synthetic leather
that's fake but it looks so different
okay so here's another image of it
now does it have 10 wheels two four six
eight wheels only oh pathetic oh no two
four six eight ten it has ten wheels my
bad
apologies Okay evan massage chair well
can I can I make a revision on that
first I I if I'm okay with it if there's
a fake leather option I'm in
so how do we need to go back and revise
the bracket well it's just this first
round right you can switch them out with
that for that yeah you're good
let's go Okay cool so here it is Evan
massage chair micro fiber leather save
the cows
we say here at the H3 Productions office
okay congratulations moving on that's
exciting so we have an iconic chair
Herman Miller chair the gold standard of
office chairs submitted by the guy
Thai guy who is Herman a king Herman
Cain I think he died from coven no not
that Herman
wasn't wasn't that company the one that
fired a bunch of people on Sue and it
went viral was it oh you might be right
yeah so well it was the one about the
bonuses the pity City yeah oh [__] oh
yeah
listen I am this is my vote I've sat in
these chairs for Dan I went to the store
I tried them out I've been hearing a lot
about the Herman Millers what are you
what are you going to say no no yeah and
I got a 20 uh code too if you want to go
this way like yeah affiliate code you're
sponsored not sponsored no no they got
me on contract for three months wait so
did you like this I I do like it yes
okay I've sat in this chair it's so
overrated like oh I don't understand the
hype people they they Rave about this
thing like it's spun from Bold it's just
not that good
a lot of mixed opinions in the chat too
I've seen people say they're so bomb so
good and then other people
[__] Herman Miller wow okay it's much
like weed well it just does it have to
be this specific Herman Miller it's the
one that you got that we have here yeah
we have so that's a different type of
chair they do make good chairs the one
that I use at home is Herman Miller this
specific model I don't like that's
interesting okay well I am interested
however
I mean I feel like it's been done a
little dirty by the bracket because I'm
already seeing what it's up against next
and well let's take a look the off-road
Chair by Bayer Bay Brit I mean this
looks incredible now this WOW action
track chair NT 10 500 dude
um so we have tank treads full Treads we
have a quite High frankly you'll be very
high up
I don't know if this is going to raise
our uh workers comp insurance premium
but everything's ready for battle bro
that's so sick I'm sorry that thing is
they say World War Three is coming Dan
Dan you're making the same mistakes
though I feel like you have an awesome
chair listen uh we you gotta have to
climb up into that
now that we we found the fake leather of
the massage chair I'm kind of thinking
that that's my fallback if I decide you
know I don't want to go for the Goofs
but
there it is I mean this thing is a tank
I mean okay hold on this is now
the price has changed it's fourteen
thousand whoa okay but it's my money you
don't have to worry about that damn I
mean think about it you'll never have to
work again
dude you're gonna look like the villain
from Wild Wild West if you go check out
the customizable
I have a question Mobility I think so I
kind of vaguely remember looking at this
on the podcast years ago when we were
looking at it was kind of like in the
discussion leading up to us getting the
Gatsby this is a Mobility Scooter that's
kind of wild ooh I like the orange
you're gonna kill someone out there
they're already dangerous enough
you're gonna give them a tank oh there's
different models down there too
those are different are there any with
any kind of like 50 caliber Vulcan
Cannon this is a rare skin actually it's
very very Gatling gun they're The Phase
Clan skin
we should be scary
so you know
um
I I this is the choice I mean between
these two
which one you choosing the tank the tank
between this and the Herman Miller also
I mean the the pity City lady [__] I
knew I was gonna say this is he's
leftist choice right here God damn it
yeah it's leftist okay industrial one is
pro-war at the same time yeah I know you
are supporting the I'm a vanguardess
dude I don't give a [__] let's go all
right get the desert storms thank you
Dan congratulations to the off-road
chair submitted by Bay Brit yeah we're
going with it we're going with it up
next by what is that arborish the vinyl
chair interesting sounds subtle but is
it
let's take a look take a look
this is oh wow
wow
uh one set of bookshelves
oh with some like with some band uh
posters on the back wait is this okay
this isn't a real product I think
someone made this oh is this design yeah
it has King Lizard on the back which was
King blizzard it's like eating down
those King Lizard
um that was a gizzard yeah it might be a
slight I like blizzard bass uh issue uh
I don't know it actually seems fairly
compact right this is uh this is
obviously like the the Uber hipster
Choice here
um but I I do like the 70s Vibes uh
I like the 70s aesthetic a lot
personally thank you by the way to
harbor-ish for Designing this very cool
yeah it's a gallery uh right we saw the
background that's just this two
um okay very cool uh I'm in I'm into it
on a on aesthetic level uh next is the
wizard Chair by WTF is space Oh yeah and
that is a good question this is a custom
dragon wing
it's pretty cool Throne wow looks nice
uh one more time give it yeah give it
another spin
there it is a mighty long Shadow yeah
like you
um looks cool
doesn't necessarily look that
comfortable I I don't the straight back
is worrying me you know what I mean sure
sure I guess if it could be designed to
lean a little bit
um I'd be more open to it but yeah I I
imagine feeling pretty uncomfortable
after a while okay fair enough so that
there you go yeah I think I I've got to
go with uh with the Hipster chair nice
I've got so many links open
there might be uh some jealousy with
Zach that that sure seems a little bit
oh the sex alley
very true and here's the vinyl there is
live in San Diego there is very possibly
a finalist in this next and final group
so up next this is the final bracket of
the first round we have the Star Trek
chair coming in this is fantastic I mean
it fits the aesthetic it fits the role
you are the captain Oh engage engage is
what and I want you to engage with this
chair sexually
I've mentioned a few times on the show
but I I don't know if everyone's aware
big Trekkie here uh especially next gen
that's my [__] Picard's my guy
um wow I mean that's now I do want to
point out this appears to be the design
from the Enterprise E not the D okay and
the D is the one from the TV show The e
is the one from the one that you want of
the different model okay let me because
if there if there's a newer generation
model I'll let you chat I'll let you
decide uh well it this is actually the
newer one it's the older one that is
more dear to my heart I see uh
Enterprise D Bridge does he get a jacket
like this
if he chooses this one jacket sold
separately
uh here let's take a look dude that's so
sick that is kind of yeah I want one I
might buy one for myself so it's very
similar it's a different color scheme
this one is installed it doesn't swivel
uh it does swivel it's just can you zoom
in more yeah
yeah let me take a closer look at that
if he chooses this one can we make the
whole set look like this dude can you
get one I mean lower res well
let's see
this one looks uh perhaps
yeah when we first moved into this room
I thought we should all do uniforms and
the whole deal I mean this is a
television set it is purposely arranged
in a way that it's quite good for
shooting a bunch of people all facing
the same direction
we could just build the Enterprise set
in here Dan is saying
let's build the Enterprise forget the
chair I want a whole damn spaceship he's
saying
um but yeah I mean this uh this seems
like a strong Contender what what is it
up against is it up against a tall order
uh well don't don't count the next one
out okay phase gaming oh a face share I
mean Facebook it's got it all right
thank you too Stan lido7 this is the
respawn Flex phase Edition respawn Flex
Phase Clan Edition is full mesh
ergonomic gaming chair that provides
breathable comfort and support see how
the flex decreases your gaming fatigue
and increases your gaming performance
that's right
300 I like how they have to say that
they're like listen Gamers 300 pounds
just got to be clear about that it's a
concern it's a concern in that industry
so this is this is fantastic well I can
see on the pole not too many votes in
yet but uh a clear blowout for the Star
Trek chair and though though I am Phase
Clan For Life though I Am A banks uh
supporter and Stan
um he's my dog for life
I think I think banks would understand I
think he would get it that I'm gonna
have to go with the Star Trek chair
there it is that's an easy Choice that's
an easy choice
let's take a look at the bracket now
let's revisit our
oh wow some fantastic options so let's
just go first back to the beginning
we have um the grandfather chair yeah
luxurious luxurious grandfather chair
off-road 10 wheels versus Rich Lux the
pink Throne yep
versus the Akira how about this how
about this the audience decides this but
you decide the final
um
okay well I don't think yeah I think
that's fine yes let's go because frankly
I'm pretty happy with this bracket I
mean wait no it's not hard
I think I just got one yeah I I think
that first round filtered out all of the
ones that that would be like a hard no
from me so I'm open to audience input
from that I love now I'm excited
and you're saying I can still have when
it what when it comes down to the final
two I'll pick okay let's do it let's
have the audience uh decide
love that dude I want tacos too dumb
between
the pink throne and the grandfather
Daddy
the pink throne and the grandfather get
your votes in people
hold on
the grandfather is a potential finalist
for you right Dan
I I would say so I'm pretty impressed by
this one
um as far as like a non-memy choice well
it is it's still pretty meme actually I
mean it's absurd
the gym
people are like no let Dan pick then
vote for what dam wants it's up to you
guys
you know what I mean oh thank you
do not vote for the rich Lux chair and
you see I knew they had your interests
in mind it's a blowout for the chair you
want okay do people care yeah I guess
the rich Lux one in is one that
I wouldn't have really wanted to win but
um but yeah if it's a blowout for
this guy the plush office chair I call
it already it's 80 grandfather all right
done boom
we're moving and grooving here we have
two Custom Designs going head-to-head
the Akira which frankly I'd be very
happy with either of these these yeah
versus The Brain Trust yep
Akira chair versus the brain the brain
trust oh the cerebro right okay
I gotta see um excuse me everyone let me
just uh hit this uh quesadilla real
quick I gotta see a shot of Love's feast
where's my food dude well you don't have
you don't have anything yet
damn that sucks bro
I order so much they're trying to
walk in there this is a tough one it's
just too much yeah
[Music]
here we go
the voting has become here we go and it
looked like the brain chairs taking it
pretty handily it is pretty pretty far
out ahead okay 70 truly uh shout out to
the designer of the Kira bike this one
definitely speaks to me as well
um
but the cerebro
the cerebro takes it and congratulations
there it is
pulling out a bit we go back to the
other side of the bracket here
oh you want two of those things
okay
we have the tank
verse the massage chair
the tank first the massage chair
and this does include prostate massaging
milking excellent all different flavors
variants of depth and speed
oh I have my food this is the future of
chairs what do we got love let's see it
well there's a bunch here oh I don't
know I
gotta see all the [__] you got
baby can you just tilt down his camera a
little bit
see what he's got
all right
this is the Taco Bell party that was
promised Taco Bell par oh okay I got a
song can't see it can you switch so I
can see it oh I was like do I need the
minimum I got a soft one this is the
fried chicken one I got the circle one
hard taco
another soft one and where's my Chupa
Loompa I told you I think that they
forgot one they forgot my shin balloon
[Applause]
see they always forget something that's
why I ordered a lot I'm still I I
ordered with them with that in mind that
they might lose something they're gonna
wrap yes so this is still enough yeah
yeah no all good all good you okay with
that the Chupa Loompa yeah it was it was
it was calculated one no actually it's
not it's um next time two two Oompa
Loompas I should have ordered two
shrimples no no I will I will get to
Jupiter makeup right now that was all
accounted for I was accounting for one
to be get lost on its way here so all
good
Taco Bell order well you know well I
learned from last time actually they did
lose one of my tacos last time so I
think the driver was just like I'm gonna
hit I'm gonna eat this and you know what
I don't blame him it's it's a tough life
as a delivery driver okay so there it is
we have uh an easy winner in the tank
chair
congratulations we love to see it folks
fantastic
going down
the tank chair where is the tank chair
it's right there at the top right I have
to
here it's called off-road that's why I
have to select the layer all right
moving on so wait
no the you put it the wrong way didn't
you oh wait no you didn't yeah never
mind my bad so up next we've got the car
good ones two good ones the bur card
versus the hipster
um
two custom jobs nerd versus hipster
Which Way Western man both very lovely
very nice
I could see Dan settle in settling into
either one of those frankly
[Music]
one will guaranteed kill Zack of
jealousy
the Picard
that is traveling Vibe isn't it
definitely
want to throw that out there for my boy
since he's not here
you can't yeah I'll throw it upload
uh so we are doing the
what are we calling the Hipster chair or
just how about like the vinyl
[__] it hipster chair hipster versus
Picard
car track Fair
all right asking the community here we
go
frankly I'd be happy with either of
these so I think I think it's a
I think Picard's got it it's iconic it's
so iconic that you would be sitting
there
Manning the Enterprise
[Music]
by the way there's a there's like a new
Star Trek show on called strange new
worlds that I've been watching really
what channel
it's on uh Paramount [__]
oh it's good you know I've warmed up to
it I was a little unsure because the
newer era of Star Trek hasn't really
been for me but um
it's pretty cool it's a prequel to The
Original Series so it's the Enterprise
before Kirk gets it and uh but a lot of
the characters from the original series
on it like spot a young Spock is on the
crew and a few other recognizable
characters that's interesting I've been
enjoying it it's pretty good
so that's a Star Trek win easy easy win
easy clap yeah
so I think the fans decide until the
finals you're good with that yeah that's
fine okay
so we're in the uh what the this is the
semi-finals this is it yep now here's
some big ones here these are these are
four fantastic options
you got the granddaddy the tank the
Picard the Brain Trust all converging
one of these will be Dan's future chair
and those are four sick chairs the
crowned
[Music]
batch chairler
all right so let's go to the granddaddy
versus The Brain Trust all right you
still need me to do it love you eating
yeah okay I got it
so the granddaddy chair versus the X-Men
you know there are two
um I just realized there are two Patrick
Stewart derived chairs in this bracket
is that right oh you're right cerebral
what an influence he has yeah
all right so the Grand Daddy chair
versus the X-Men chair I'm going to ask
so coming in on the final poll here
granddaddy vs X-Men how we feeling
here we go oh it's close this is closer
than we've seen yeah oh the granddaddy
is pulling ahead though
and that's the winner I expected frankly
as Dan expressed his
love and interest I'm somewhat relieved
just because I feel like it would be
quite a task to actually fabricate that
custom one as cool as it is and I'm sure
we could find somebody but uh one is
ready-made versus that would without a
doubt be the most annoying
artists right to make
the granddaddy chair you can have by
next week apparently
like two yeah two business days versus
like hiring somebody to make it for the
next three months or something
so that's a that's a dub for the daddy
all right the granddaddy has won out
though a lot of supporters
for cerebro got 41 not bad all right
granddaddy where are you it's called the
plush office chair there we go all right
that's a finalist that's our first
finalist congratulations to the
Granddaddy and a beautiful chair frankly
beautiful
did we mention it has 10 wheels my
goodness my God submitted by just
peachy99 just peachy good night
now this is very interesting on one
bracket you have 10 wheels on the other
bracket side both zero wheeled well yeah
I guess you could say that up top Wheels
it's on Treads yeah it's on Treads yeah
and Below Picard's is stationary right
right
um so
let's take it to the polls guys this
one's tough this is these are both
favorites
we have the tank
verse the Picard
[Music]
that's Captain John Luke are we going to
be exploring the battlefield or space
itself you decide right
what kind of Picard I mean he is a
diplomat first but he's a warrior as
well you know
cool I could see him in either one of
these yeah Space Mountain without Dan
ruining my vacation
well
as I expected a card
has taken it down
wait why did I do bad pull
no this is a bad pool it's not
you're fine
it's because the order isn't the same as
it is on screen oh I'm sorry
that is kind of a bad pull oh should we
redo it
Dan loves just torturing someone else
I've seen a lot of bad pole
it's not that bad welcome by the way
all right two tacos down I'm done
very good
thank you guys
so we are redoing the pull because it
was clearly a bad it was a bad pull all
right guys it's okay love it's okay now
I'm better love is learning he just got
here folks
I'm sorry he doesn't know better I'm
sorry oh
so now the pull is back in the correct
order
[Music]
results are the same
identical
laughs
literally identical results
67 Star Trek chair we can take it down
guys like I understand it's identical
but
we always would have been in doubt if we
didn't no you're right we always would
have wondered it was it just because of
a bad pull fair enough
but now now we know truth and accuracy
is Paramount what's the name of the game
here on the History podcast
both with us and Colleen's lawyers which
I totally agree with
we are aligned on that all right now
this is where it gets really interesting
I don't know which one's going to win
here and frankly because you said I I
could um I could choose between these
two this is up to you frankly I mean I'm
not going to say that it's binding but I
would like the audience's input on this
still because I am indecisive here these
are both incredible options want the
option away I don't know when or how
long it's going to take to get the
Picard chair in here we might have to
custom build that uh we likely would you
know what's funny
I don't want to say too much I have a
connection to somebody that could like a
help us make that in a extremely
Accurate Way okay somebody that may have
had something to do with production on
the show well that's good then because
one of my words of caution to you
was going to be in the granddaddy chair
you've guaranteed got yourself a new
beautiful chair next week
Star Trek chair it's a big question mark
right
both spectacular though
both phenomenal so I'm seeing the chat
the grandpa chair is winning though it
is close it is very close
53 to 47 could not be closer it could be
but not a lot it could but literally it
could be
I mean
if we're being honest I mean the massage
chair is built for Comfort right like
that that is likely to be the more
comfortable of the two so the the
it's like a
a prop or or part of a TV set it the
Picard one looks pretty comfortable
right like that doesn't look like a
terrible chair
hold on I just got I just found out why
our last episode was demonetized guess
what it was
uh talking about a gaping [__] nope
really wasn't that
what else did we you're talking about
Wednesday's episode right nice Olivia
um
it's always the dumbest thing yeah
always let me think about it let me
think about it viral hog [__] let me let
me look at the time stamps
I'll I'm just I'm just gonna tell you
because I don't think you're gonna guess
it no depiction of pranks or challenges
that fall under are harmful or dangerous
act policy in this case eating edible
substances harmful in large volume the
chip yeah
that's [__] dumb
[__] that's interesting the [__] chip
I mean we did the chipper it was scary
the chip
could it be the that uh or that uh Lena
A2 the double chip the double is like
too far yeah it could have been the
double chip I'll ask is that in in like
larger quantities
too bad I guess I can't do it then
you already won love no but if this is
the reason that YouTube is sexist
dude they're so annoying though they're
like if you only ate one chip it would
have been a totally different story but
because she had two we gotta demonetize
your four and a half hour podcast
tube's got a chip limit four and a half
hours of content exceeded the
exceeded the trip limit wow
always oh that's a bummer we're like wow
it must have been the butthole stuff
nope they don't care about that and now
that's all well clearly they don't it's
on YouTube Just reacting to a YouTube
video I always thought the butthole
stuff was fine because it really does
fall under their description of like
being an educational we didn't show
anything yeah Chad's saying then hot
ones should be demonetized yeah what the
[__] what the hell dude they're ten
different levels thank you
I'm gonna ask that
that's [__] [__] I wanted to kill
somebody why can hot ones
it's a fantastic I have ads
and we can't we're gonna [__] over hot
ones with that question rather than
unmonetize us they're just gonna
demonetize the hot ones Channel good
point the whole Channel Sean Evans it's
gonna be so mad
damn that's insane yeah it makes no
sense it's just so stupid
all right
so I think we have a new goal get hot
ones fully demonetized
for you we're coming for you dude
welcome
um there you go Dan the the decision is
yours
uh 54 says Grandpa chair
can I get any input from you guys like
what do you guys think because I I'm
genuinely torn Star Trek and I'm not
Star Trek saying that to stretch this
out I I am genuinely torn these both
seem like great options let me see again
I feel like long term
the the grandpa chair like makes more
sense as like a comfortable chair to be
sitting in every day right but
the cool factor is so high and
on top of that it doesn't look like an
uncomfortable chair you know what I mean
despite it being like a meme chair it
actually the the card one still looks
comfy okay well let me remind you
somebody's gonna be building that who
specializes in doing props not building
chairs right right the chance that it's
actually comfortable very low
but it's not going to be as bad as the
Scorpion chair no it couldn't be it
couldn't be but then on the other hand
this Grandpa chair these chairs are also
sometimes not as comfortable as they
look because it's just so ridiculously
over the top I agree I don't think it
looks comfortable I feel like it's
you're not going to be able to get it
close to the table yeah you're not going
to have to slide like you can't slide it
under the table like you want to do
I think these are both the other one
doesn't slide at all well
yeah so then the grandfather chair
you're going to get immediately the Star
Trek chair is just a big question mark
dude we're in Hollywood the actors are
on strike we're gonna sneak on set and
steal the actual Star Trek probably
nobody's on set right I mean ironically
uh I'm sure
um I'm sure the uh
set Builders or art Department people
that do this kind of stuff would be
happy for some work because everything
else is shut down we should have Malik
Vegas I mean maybe he's very crafty
so ultimately
you're choosing style or substance
that's that's just yeah
all I heard in the room was was Star
Trek chair is there anybody that
disagrees with that or is everybody like
I didn't say either way I think you're
[__] either way I feel like this I
think this is a new Noah scorpion
boondoggle it can't be that bad I mean
because I feel like he's gonna have
trouble reaching his monitor and being
because you have to lean over I feel
like in both of them you can well so but
I think he deserves it you can you can
block it so it doesn't lean back
yeah but the concerns over there the
concerns over the granddaddy chair are
real
dude you know what too you know what I
just realized that kind of pushes me
towards the Star Trek is that in the
show on the arms he has like little
digital control panels or whatever yeah
could embed my [__] stream decking
and I could literally but the button
that is that is so you're gonna say put
the button in there yeah dude boom I
thought you're gonna say there's someone
who sits on his right oh the coolness
factor of that I wouldn't put the button
in there that's dangerous you're just
gonna be hitting that thing on accident
I guess that's maybe true
um smash that button
I think I gotta I I think the nerd in me
is is too strong I think I gotta pick
the Star Trek chair make it so make it
so
and there we have a winner uh triumphant
music is playing everybody is playing
creepy music actually
the captain has been crowned the king is
born
there we go okay now we got something
upbeat all right let's [__] go
dude
you know in the Star Trek like analogy
though like I know I know I'm bald so
like it makes sense Picard or whatever
but I feel like you're the captain and
I'm number one I'm Riker maybe I'm an
admiral you know I'm I'm above well the
ab rolls are usually [__] in that
show you know yeah like always yeah they
are is there ever a good Admiral very
rarely
okay well you're saying I should take
the Star Trek chair I'm not saying that
and actually Riker had the same chair
true yeah so it's all good true yeah
well there it is so that basically we
have a lot of work ahead of us we have
to
yeah we gotta figure out I'll we'll talk
after the show I I legitimately have a
very good in for making this happen so
there it is so there it is we have a
project thank you and thank you
everybody who submitted a lot of very
funny very good options in there uh I I
thought I was gonna get trolled more
most of those were cool like almost all
of those I would have been cool I think
you have Ian to think for the yes thank
you Ian for for not putting too many
troll ones I think I saw an Iron Maiden
at one point well there was like the [__]
chair and the uh and the McDonald's one
are the only ones that I would say are
like purely true to be frank Dan if I
were you and I'm not even joking I would
consider the Ronald McDonald chair it's
just so funny it's very funny what is
not that bad a wooden bench it's not
gonna be bad it's it's it's basic it's
you know sitting in there five days a
week I don't think it'd be that bad
not that bad all right let's get to work
people
area and you are um
what what would a what's like a like a
cobbler make shoes like like a black
earth works like what's what's a
carpenter is it just a carpenter
probably a carpet if you're if you're a
talented Carpenter and you think this is
a project that you could take on uh I'd
be open to uh hearing from you give me
an email serious submission Zone oh here
it's called a chair blur professional
swear to God a terribleer I swear it's
called a chair blur obsessed with that
that's awesome do you know any chair
blurs if you're a terribleer in the uh
greater Los Angeles area and you would
like to assist in this project uh feel
free to reach out uh I am open to
suggestions if you got a game plan with
it
um I'm open to reaching out to Malik and
see if if that's something he wants to
pick on too I don't know his traveler uh
credentials yeah yeah yeah he's more
specialized in um [__] holes yeah things
that you can [__] right yeah but he's
very talented you never know he is I
have someone too that's an engineer that
might be able to oh okay put some bells
and whistle we'll talk after the show
there's we got some options I'm still
game to sneak on set and steal it who's
with me uh I'm with you Kim uh maybe I'm
on a visa to the gates of hell yes we
won't get caught don't worry it's not
illegal if you don't get it they did
just very recently because of the last
season of Picard they remade
the original the one that I pulled up
the the Enterprise D they remade that
whole set for that show
um so there is a there's a fresh chair
sitting in a warehouse somewhere it's
ours let's take it
well moving on congratulations thank you
thank you it's finally done it's finally
finally done but I got to be frank your
choice leaves you in that chair for an
undetermined amount of time
uh no I'm ditching it next Tuesday oh
you're just gonna get I'll just sit in a
normal that's part of the rules bro you
can't replace it I know it gets here
because we gotta rearrange the whole
control room to make room for love okay
so there you go damn will be free next
week
Monday Monday will be the uh scorpion
Sheriff what are you gonna do with that
thing
I I think we'll just put it in the
museum of dead H3 podcast shows oh true
yeah just move it over there yeah yeah
it's it's worthy of that yeah it's a
museum piece right absolutely yeah I
just found the Lost tacos thank you you
ate it all yeah whoa dude dude I eat a
lot like yeah no [__] a lot of food
without any issues look at that pile of
of Taco bones thank you very much for
the food absolutely thank you
forgetting my whole show demonetized
just kidding
that makes no sense I'm actually
it's like they have no consideration for
the idea that I'm running a business
with nine full-time employees with rent
with gear it's like oh he had a chip
demonetized I mean what the [__]
I think you have a very good counter
argument with the hot ones there I wrote
them they clearly uh are okay with that
behavior yeah
I don't know a spicy chip are you
serious right now
I don't know
um let's see we have a little bit of
time left have we gone over three hours
uh we are just under three hours so we
have the James Charles article which
frankly oh I want to do the Fouseytube
let's do that okay I was just about to
do that before Ed's called in
yes so fusi's been IRL streaming
and people can donate
to have a voice read off their message
and of course
people are capitalizing on this to the
most I still can't go over the fact that
he's faking his sub count it's crazy how
do you know that because we watch him a
lot especially yeah oh you do you're a
fan yeah a few of us here
tune into his stream yeah we enjoy his
dreams a lot let's just say that some of
us but we've seen him physically type in
the sub count yes it goes away and then
could that just be him he doesn't know
how to set up the automation so he does
not manually I input it he knows how to
text the speech he knows how to do it
there is a problem sometimes when you
use on like stream elements where it
messes up and you do have to type it
back in so it's accurate I will say that
I don't know if that's what he's doing I
haven't watched it and he he does he
gets views does he not no no it's not
ten thousand so we watch his streams and
there's no subs in the shot there's like
one every now and then he does not gain
like
and also to add on to what love is
saying I watched a 10 minute clip and I
did not see one sub within 10 minutes
which I was I was surprised that is
surprising yeah okay definitely so his
real sub count could be like 300 or
something I would probably 700 maybe in
the whole stream too he's constantly
flexing his sub count he's like in the
50th most subscribed in the world right
now guys the bill will be in about in
about two weeks he should Drop Like 6
000 Subs yes they all should be about 30
days yeah so wait what how is this real
that he's doing you know what actually
to add on to that now that I think about
it before that 10 minutes that I'm
talking about he's like I'm about to
tell a story story so nobody donate
which usually on Twitch people are like
all right that means I'm gonna [__] with
him and donate nobody donated for those
10 minutes but it's a respectful
audience I appreciate that no after
dealing with our audience all the time I
think he was setting himself up so when
people say about just said that in 10
minutes I didn't see one sub you could
say well I told them don't donate yeah
and that's an empty audience
right so here it is anyway uh Fouseytube
the 50th most sub-channel on Twitch very
exciting for him please
sure I don't want to wait in line oh
I saw this clip on Reddit it went Mega
viral on like entitled [__] or
something like that so yeah or maybe it
was I'm the main character I saw it
there as well and frankly if he's being
serious this is this is stunning I mean
this is really really stunning stuff
can I ask you something
please sure I don't want to wait in line
can you get my coffee and then I'll pay
you for it
it's ruining my live stream oh that's so
unfortunate you can get it back in life
for Content I'm number 69 in the world
right now I gotta keep the content there
he is plugging his yeah sub count
constantly
that's so sad that he's doing that
actually depressing and sad it's very
sad his dream does have an aura of like
sad and like is it like a train wreck is
that why you guys watch well it's like
these weird small quirks that just makes
me giggle like crazy like he has his dog
in a bag and just his head sticks out
and then he forgets the dog is in the
bag so he's like too rough with the bag
and like what what the heck he's so
funny and sometimes when he's out eating
at a restaurant too like he'll have the
camera on people that are clearly
uncomfortable with it like just
restaurant patrons so it's like the good
old days like Poseidon yeah like most of
these streamers are banned by now but
he's like rejuvenating him it's gonna be
gone soon yeah yeah unfortunately
probably for animal abuse by the way
he's
it's just like that's you do you
remember there's a dog in there I did
not [__] my dog dude he's live right now
I just saw this text-to-speech give me
the link I want to pull it out yeah
you're gonna know what I mean it's just
like
this thing off
he's been live for like 10 days [__]
actually give me the link I want to tune
in real fast we sent it anorexic Cat 2
donated five dollars message from mom
son please don't shoot the driver you
have so much to live for I didn't read
that oh Jesus yeah it's already awesome
that's insane just caught that live he
he actually happened he keeps showing
his phone with an address I don't know
why this is a search
I gotta wait for these damn ads
apparently oh there's well there's a
thousand people watching I don't know
how many just came from our show but
1400 watching which is not bad
everybody's hyped about number 44.
number 44 in the world baby let's go and
it's the mod saying it too
so here it is this is more fun
times
I'll cash up you right away I'll sell
you I'll even pay you extra
I'll double the price of the drink I
just want to ice Block Coffee
Nitro not a one of you not it not like
he's probably positioning I'm like I'll
give you two dollars
just a black coffee I'll give you eight
dollars to piss off this line of people
behind not even eight dude he wanted an
ice black coffee that's two bucks no but
he specified he wanted he wants it Nitro
oh he wants that nice yeah
and I mean dude you've got 10 000 Subs
man sweeten the deal a little bit
you're rolling in it that's actually
crazy
I'm sick in Hindi what
gosh Shady excuse me so I was like oh
he's just being a troll but then he goes
and actually complains that they would
not let him cut in line ask you a
question
[Music]
I've been waiting just as long okay
and y'all are so seriously seriously
society and civilization is so [__] up
they're so like they're so awesome don't
talk to me I'm in public human
interaction used to be a normal thing
human interaction used to be a normal
thing and my Dad's Deli at my Dad's Deli
when patrons couldn't pay me it's a huge
social commentary that people won't let
them cut I have a massive update I'm
completely mindful I went this is crazy
I went on his twitch you can make your
subs public he has 1300 Subs what the
[__] oh my God whoa he has 1400 Subs
right now so he's crushing it or 1 400
or 14 000. I've got guys naked trying to
fix the TTS on screen right now
and messing up and Nick is trying to fix
it filming this guy taking camera chat
keeps being like don't kill the Uber
driver wow but like really that video of
him walking around being like damn
social interaction that looks like a
performance piece because he is so
connect like disconnected from the world
around he's wearing like a headset has a
camera he's literally interacting with
the only non-people there yeah and he's
like human interaction he's talking to
the internet are you kidding me I think
we should remember that
it's possible I haven't been watching
enough I don't know y'all are seeing me
it is possible
seeing what I do to post all my posts on
social media I want y'all to be a part
of that too I'm a little worried about
that because
that's something that happens with him
oh yeah he's had a few uh episodes he's
bipolar he's bipolar and he has manic
episodes
and the thing is um
he's been on a bender you guys say he's
been living for three days straight like
crazy oh that's yeah that's not that's a
that's indicative of a manic state but
he has 14 000 Subs do you I then I'm
proposing does he subscribe to himself
but he usually has like 800 viewers well
he she in the clip I watched last night
he was saying when he started streaming
he was going around 100 viewers and like
it's crazy why is everyone saying H3 oh
my God I forget I forget that they this
can happen he's going to start traveling
a lot for IRL streams you should get TSA
pre-check so you can
you're right
why did Siri say hello this is the
weirdest driver has ever had in his life
man does he have his shoes his shoes are
off yeah dude do not get that
comfortable in this man's Uber man why
not Society is [__] to slap the
absolute dog [__] out of you yeah my dad
used to take his pants off in Texas are
you okay to save the crease no I'm
kidding I'm saying how he said with this
airport thank you for even hanging up
hanging out with me
on my way to the airport
live streaming everyone especially after
getting fired today I like the company
thank you
oh no
H3 is talking [__] about you that's not
true
is that true h3s are walking out that is
oh God we're warring now our communities
are warring
to find people owner over in
fouseytube's live chat are upset
are you taking us on the flight they're
done they're they're taking a moment
from making bomb threats at Best Buy
employees too
uh anyway that's oh my God for the order
they would tell him Sal put me in the
books oh [__] he's going to the airport
he's going to get arrested yeah this is
great content wait if he's going to the
airport and he's got this live [__]
that's how ice percent got it yeah
that's how he Advanced old carrier
originally yeah wait wait this is this
is
somebody warned him that's what I'm
trying for the Walter White game right
now we're screaming in the cars don't do
it
hey
not at the airport every single time I
watch your podcast I had to hear myself
say I am gay and get ridiculed for it no
me messing up my Freudian slip and
messing up radiant slipped wait wait
wait
it means that that is his like his true
self wait yeah
[Laughter]
these comments are awesome H3 h3npc
robot demasculated
live right now oh [__] yeah let's go
okay wait I gotta firstly do not go to
the airport with the live stream on this
is so important that you that you hear
this you are gonna get arrested bro
don't do it
you're gonna get arrested bro do not
live stream at the airport
just like when you put two prank calls
on with each other someone just gifted
10 steps by the way no no oh no he's
gonna react to the phone he's hearing
what we need to hear he's here wait wait
Star Killer just said I'm trying to warn
him I don't know how to donate five
dollars
Lucy please bro it's exactly what I'm
trying to say what what's wrong with
that what wait what what's wrong with
that buddy wait what what's wrong with
that buddy what what's happening wait
what is wrong with me is this he's just
streaming buddy at me
I mean
hey to everybody watching H3 HD right
now self promo I'm live 247 my live
stream never turns off my life is on
camera 24
7.tv backslash fousey no matter what
time
this is the part where we were telling
them
almost subscribed in the world he's
missing the world we're trying to do
your favorite promo W promo so yeah H3
yeah H3 I mean I'm watching your stream
they know
literally got arrested for doing that
why
you can't think of one reason why
dude this is amazing
Inception is awesome
he's actually getting the message
don't do it [__] don't do it what's
wrong with that buddy all right I'm just
gonna talk to you now because you're
watching right I'm gonna mute it and I'm
just talking to you now
if you do this at the airport people are
gonna troll you like they've been doing
and at the airport they do not [__]
around you will be arrested
hopefully before you get on the plane
because if it's during the plane you're
probably gonna get investigated by the
FDI FBI you're definitely gonna get
banned on Twitch by the way if the
police come whatever you got going on
now that's good congratulations on the
13 000 Subs but you're about to lose it
all and I'm looking out for you buddy
buddy and as a fellow Eric brother do
not stream at the airport there it is I
couldn't say that yeah I can literally
cure everything in the world
this is amazing I love the internet I
love this so much dude this is [__]
great internet rules
2002.
let me see what he says about the gifted
yeah
[Music]
wait he wants to know what you have to
say about the gifteds
[__] this is important hopefully before
you even on the plane because if it's
during the plane you're probably gonna
get in basketball is it going in his
head or no will I get arrested y'all
look at you he kind of rocks let's be
real like this is hilarious everybody in
chat is saying yes don't do it 100 don't
do it
literally this happened yeah his life
his life was ruined he lost everything
he's back though he has to deal with um
do people watch him though yeah he's
doing pretty good actually okay you'll
end up on kids yeah didn't you just get
arrested in Thailand
whoa he's a grilling okay King
I thought it was a retainer
oh it's not enough to turn the stream
off by the way or TTS off you need to
turn the stream off yeah
I've tried my best I I don't I'm gonna
see the headline you did the right thing
to try and give him a heads up hopefully
he'll listen do you understand why this
it's funny to watch or like
somewhat entertaining I don't want to
make fun but yeah what I was saying
though is that
I think it's possible he's in the
beginning stages of a manic State and
again I'm not diagnosing I just know
he's done this before like when he did
the Drake concert and stuff and I know
it it ended up being really bad for his
mental health at the time so yeah with
that in mind maybe I hope that there's
people in his life that are like you
know keeping an eye on him and making
sure he's like
if I'm not mistaken he's saying for you
to to uh donate a thousand Subs why the
[__] would I do he said he just won a 54
million lawsuit
me yeah for what
I don't know I jumped in at the end
that's news to us this is me right now
food seed this is me right now but
please listen
if it doesn't get through to him I
really hope his driver says something
he's like I heard people think that
you're gonna get no he's like I heard
people saying you're gonna get arrested
maybe don't do it before he just hops
out of the car like I would I think the
the driver's already tipping off the FBI
I don't think he's got a shot
all right so anyway
keep an eye on fusi's stream if anything
interesting happens I'm gonna have to go
home and watch that because I gotta see
oh that's good content if I may real
quick fousey say it again I'm listening
I'll relay the message say it again oh
well I'll open it if that's the case
my new album is dropping soon and I want
uh AV is getting a message from fousey
from the other side because these are
clear our AVS are Clairvoyant he's
speaking to the spirit of Fouseytube
medium
I am forced to watch this commercial so
I can't open the Stream
the thing is there's like a minute delay
it's not the best way to communicate
it's not great
it's not great no
Morse code is faster a lot faster
here maybe I'll just start clicking
he's looking at the meme through to him
I really hope his driver says something
he definitely received the driver's
license
this is so bizarre
just hops out of the car so meta it's
crazy the driver's already tipping off
the FBI
broke yeah you know
a driver stream
going to jail you're going to jail
tonight
say it again I'm listening okay Ethan
Ethan Ethan yes
you won 54 million dollars in your
lawsuit I'm broke is he the Thousand
Years like I mean Israeli gifting a
thousand must just be confusing it with
some other stuff oh [__] you can change
this is history
so
here maybe I'll just start clicking
he said it as uh as a Jewish man if you
were to donate a thousand dollars
when did he say that
you know
he's right though I mean we could solve
the entire time save a lot of lives
today Lucy you are going to jail tonight
brother
there's no question about it
we should talk about a certain website
whatever fine
I'm going to the airport and I'm live
streaming everything
I think we may have had the opposite
effects
he says he's going through TSA at full
volume oh dude bro this is like this is
actually good can we wrap up the podcast
I know we got to wrap this up I gotta
watch this
let's rush over to the airport
no he's like
tackle him
y'all are some haters age three we love
you
thank you
oh my God I hope he's good there's so
much I smell like garlic
you smell like garlic bread that's why I
don't put it in front of the AC vent in
the public car
all right I can't do this anymore it's
oh my God I need to skip melting my
brain
[Music]
I'll be uh doing research there's
definitely something that's going to go
down at the airport no I tried we tried
we tried you tried I'm going through the
TSA with full volume on he is gonna he's
not even gonna make it to the airplane
bro he's being so defiant dude but I'm
going he's like doing the opposite just
because
like I'm one that doesn't consider the
consequences as much as I should but
this is on a whole different level
all right
I love the Freudian swim
that was hilarious that was my favorite
it was so good
I felt gay Freudian slip he's like they
didn't understand that that was a
Freudian slip which means I didn't mean
it I think when you have a special
episode where we just keep watching him
all night yeah
I think so too how far is he from the
airport
it looked like they were inching up
we gotta end before do I have an extra
hour can I just keep watching him
um you can watch you can watch them all
night if you want let me check with Ila
if we have well at this point we should
just FaceTime let's talk to him I don't
want to be on I don't want to be
participate in what's about to happen I
want to be a silent viewer we have try
we tried and he's like no I'm going to
the airport I'm gonna go on the airplane
all that [__] so I feel like we did our
part here oh yeah more more than our
partner with that being said I think I'm
gonna stay late to watch this did you
say he's gonna miss his flight
shout out 40 inch jinkos for the three
shout out hopeful flipper for the
subscription Prime shout out traffic
Conte for the five shout out traffic
content for the five stoop kid plays for
the five
really well people uh hypocrite
JT Dingle oh you think yeah
did you hear that he shouted at our boy
all right I'm just gonna wait till he's
done talking
shout out to Leah for the first time
subscription at tier one I appreciate
you Delia
I just can't get over the driver's
license this whole thing
um
I'm trying to determine how far is he
from the airport I know he said how far
he is 3K viewers I was happening cuz
Adele
yo can I stream at the air oh [__]
honestly
I don't recommend it I'll turn the TTS
off
okay okay no it doesn't matter
I mean it'll help but I think we
actually may have saved his life the TTS
is the main issue is it not what's the
other issue
I want to hear this why don't you
recommend it tell me because you're
under my name so if anything happens I
lose my job bro really wait who yeah
that should be the show you man I know
people out there waiting for all that
stuff
we'll be here you know we'll wait for
you when you arrive Houston but like
maybe someone bought his ticket yeah
you're under my name on the flight in
the world yeah wait he's taking a flight
under someone else's name that's illegal
isn't it well maybe someone just bought
it for him from Delta can you get
another airline oh my god dude he's
literally
as an Arab this is making me so
uncomfortable yeah he just said well
there's Southwest there's Virgin
Atlantic there's Emirate Airlines
I'll get you a job with Qatar Airways
four people watching you go to jail
ain't nobody going to jail trying to
contact but shout out to 3 400 people
watching if you don't know these cameras
never turn off so right now I'm flying
to Houston so the cameras will turn off
for four hours
seven when I shower when I [__] when I
eat when I ever go on a date I had to go
to jail my life Truman show 24 7. and
humans don't talk to each other anymore
that's something normal
so if you have an Amazon Prime and you
can give it free gifted I would
appreciate it so I don't I don't know if
his friend got there
shouts out h3h3 I think he I think
his friend is still on the phone
shout out to you so what I gathered is
his friend maybe works for the airline
and got him a ticket
and he says if you get arrested or do
some dumb [__] I'll lose my job
because I met he said something about I
can get you another job with a different
Airline I think he said
journey and motivational speech number
532 incoming guys be
I honestly think Bill gives twitch
I'm taking about 10 Adderalls a day dude
I'm smoking I don't do crack so I'm not
doing crack that's good um
for two years wait he said is he being
he's taking 10 Adderall a day this is
not a good situation fousey
ah
brother he takes three Sonic's of four
perks he said that a day what just said
it now that you mute it what what you
can't stream at the airport why poor
Sonics
really
yeah for what
I don't I don't know what the what the
reason is Amy Lowell what thank you so
much Amy little what thank you so much
I don't know why he keeps asking why
it's like people are going to call a
bomb threat from your phone what the
[__] why is this such a big deal I'm
just gonna be streaming to you man
uh apparently somebody that is a past
streamer on a DC yeah
they'll literally just [__] with him
they'll prank calls say someone in a red
hat with a blue [__] Grill in his
mouth
oh yeah he doesn't have to yeah
I saw cam once on Instagram live while
he was at the airport when he first
started here and I called him up I'm
like cam you should probably end it
tomorrow sweet innocent cam out there I
was just bored yeah but I didn't can I
live stream through TSA here we go
Reddit
he's called two friends he heard me say
he called two friends they're like don't
do it one of his friends is even like
I'll get fired there's consequences for
me as well now he's on Reddit asking um
any part of the secure area of an
airport and it's definitely not okay to
record or broadcast any part of the
security
until you leave
the right way to be invited into the
back room for questioning damn
the questioning I mean that would be
fantastic the interrogation yeah yeah I
wanted to stream through TSA though but
they're saying I can't now
I don't know that's that's the risk bro
I don't know but let me ask you this let
me ask you this I have 3 400 people
watching what is the chances I say [__]
it and just do it yes
3 400 people watching like do you think
that'll make a difference keep calling
someone's gonna tell them yes just keep
calling h3hd just watch me live yeah is
watching live can I take it through TSA
pick it up blow it up blow it up
blow it up blow it up through the
airport no I didn't even post it on
Instagram I just posted a tick tock no I
know it probably was just bad that's
that's probably getting a hell of people
to go watch your [__]
is Tick Tock hey shout out disappointed
Cowboy subscribing for the first time I
loved here
for themselves when you're watching me
subscribe welcome to G7 I think yeah
unless he's worried about getting fired
right let me see how much it might be
right where we're sending so many people
to go watch and he's getting all hyped
up yeah he's getting hyped up by the
viewership that doesn't want to end
because we're watching I think but we're
actually hurting things about having
people go to his stream now he really
doesn't want to stop because he's
getting choose your numbers who said
that it's so interesting
everybody's selling them don't do it
tier one subscription it's so serious
dog I appreciate that you're gonna get
arrested
you're gonna lose your job it's gonna
get back before he gets there I think
you think so yeah
are you serious
yeah that too he's worried about missing
his flight because he's running late
I'll cancel the flight really that's a
good friend finally
[Music]
his friend says I'm canceling the flight
if you do this he just saved your life
some idiot watching will call the
airport and tell them you're going to do
something yes I'm sorry but it's the
nature of dumbasses online
all love oh thank you so much for the 20
bomb Mega awesome I understand now
Avery you're amazing wavery in
everything
July 15th is it July 15th tomorrow
the news for a bomb threat the day
before July 15th I'm literally done for
life that's what I'm saying don't not
worth it it's not worth it thank you so
much honey Melo for the subscription
it's not working dog tell me when you're
writing it EB
all right
don't do it you're gonna get banned on
Twitch
you're gonna lose everything
also I think there's a character limit
um yeah 200 so where are we now don't do
it you'll get banned on Twitch you will
lose everything and as do we have more
space yeah we have 186 characters say
and Ryan Cavanaugh
no
[Music]
can we say Ryan Kavanaugh and we can say
Ryan Cavanaugh yeah and Ryan Kavanaugh
looks like someone or Ryan Cavanaugh
does Ryan Kavanaugh look like Harvey
weinstein.com
he just got a bunch of gifted and now if
he's gonna continue no he's not he's not
there's no way
there's no way his friend said he's
going to cancel the flight oh gifted
okay don't do it you'll get banned on
Twitch you will lose everything and does
Ryan Kevin all look like Harvey
weinstein.com
oh it fits yeah great let's do it
that's a good plug for us actually
that's what's up bro it's [__] wild
I'm almost at the airport y'all a couple
of minutes okay so I'm sticking around I
gotta make sure you I gotta make sure he
turns it off
we we all have been here for the ride we
have to make sure he's gonna take
everyone else
is getting pretty Juiced yeah it's too
much with 10 gifts juices
if the driver can hear this take him
back home driver turn around
that would be a good donut did you
donate
over
because people can do anything yes stay
safe and we will see you when you land
sir can I ask you a question no
he's hoping he'll say yes I recorded
inside the gym do you think I would get
in trouble
I mean inside the airport
I don't know exactly I just drive an
Uber bro come on bro say yes he's been
listening to us list the rules
wait don't do it you will get banned on
Twitch you will lose everything and as
Ryan Kavanaugh look like Harvey
weinstein.com okay I think it got
through to him though wow App Store hey
thank you so much okay no problem
okay shout out a b I'm showing your
boxing match dog oh he knows no one
knows what it takes to get into the
[__] place
I will turn it off y'all
I believe it there you go
we did it we did it we did it
I think it's just gonna turn it off
before he gets to security because he
said before I'm gonna bring you guys in
better than what we have I gotta make
sure he we gotta hold him accountable
come on you're gonna play me like that
I I got I'm going till it gets to the
airport we're invested now
we're invested
I'm looking for the scary music
Verizon's 5G Network let's go
let's go at 5G 5G let's go
5G AF
oh I'm excited for Oppenheimer by the
way Oppenheimer is anyone excited for
that
yeah I'm definitely gonna go by all
accounts it seems like this are you
gonna do the film what do they call it
the carbon hybrid double feature back to
back oh the barber comes out the same
day a lot of people are booking double
features I'm really excited about Barbie
to be honest uh there's so much hype
about that movie I just
[Music]
until I started seeing some of the clips
for it and it genuinely seemed pretty
funny I don't know yeah it seems like
it's it's very self-aware and
goofy My Hope Is that it'd be like some
kind of like almost
like a Truman Show asked like I think
it's psychological Thriller
but I don't think it is I think it's
just a goofy comedy
[Music]
damn it's a long commercial what the
[__] yeah zero five odds
oh he's back he's back what we did four
times even though it's a big deal but my
new model in life is if there's nothing
you can do about it if the damage is
done and it's your fault
I could cry about it for the next two
years so he's gonna do it again I'm wait
that doesn't support your theory wait is
that him saying like you know what it's
my decision I'm doing it
we said if there's nothing you can do
about it you can do everything about it
no I don't have his number yeah
if anything do I even follow him I think
I unfollowed him
oh is he following you
I think he's talking about someone else
uh sorry Ethan not this time oh he's
getting close you guys I can feel it
don't follow him he unfollowed me to no
that's the HC podcast oh no he is
talking about you did we follow he's
following you right now I'll follow him
wait what does that mean on Twitter he's
following you oh I follow him too what
is he
let me see if he ever DM me his phone
just get it oh yeah it's right here he's
gonna leave my phone number four five
six seven no three he did he did he did
he did he did what the [__] did he just
say wait delete that clip delete that
clip delete that clip oh my God oh my
God your number wait wait what just
happened delete that clip delete that
clip what the [__] was happening
I didn't hear it I didn't hear the
number he said can I go back it didn't
sound like a guy it sounded like he was
counting to 10.
because I was like I didn't hear my
number A lot of times
I can't go through that again A lot of
times they did troll us don't risk it
all for a few moments of attention
you're so right who do I got a shout out
I just got a subscription by the way if
you're new here I don't like to miss any
gifteds or subscriptions y'all are
spending your hard-earned money I
recently went broke and no like I know
what money is now I never knew you know
what money is so I'm able to say I do
think he's right I mean he's making
money right now so much but I do think
he lost everything after the Drake crime
tier one magic dude Uzi 1990 with the
five the pizza the man with the gifted
give yours
a number gifted it would have been your
old number though right it wasn't your
number let me see what I messaged him
right all right because it would have
been a while ago before the recent
incident right
yeah oh yeah for sure right so but let
me see what I went back and looked it
wasn't your number okay so if I look in
the DM
I did send him my phone my stream at the
airport
but it's my old number
right that's that's what I figured yeah
either but it sounds like cam just said
he just went back and it was just a
troll okay
you can call me fousey should I call him
and he also updates
he's recording the screen all the time
like the title um on the airplane
heading to Houston and also put on a
pencil I don't know when he gets
arrested at the airport you're gonna be
the last number called I should have
kept nice for the subscription big one
month this
realizing and showing the 2 000 new
people we're telling you not to do it
we're here at the airport that's such
bad timing no it's not
it's not there's a reason why we're here
right now thank you bro we're here to
save you
all right he thinks it's just a
coincidence today is different than any
other because you are about to stream at
the airport that's why we're watching
right now he thinks because you have to
stop I uh oh
is this it
all right y'all I appreciate you yes I
love you all thank y'all so much for the
support we're not ending I'm just going
on the plane for a couple of hours oh
I'm just going on the plane for a couple
did he end it he can have a service that
continues this stream without him
actually ending it okay but he I think
he officially he's not yeah okay
Avery said when uh there was an ad break
uh he said that we are right and he
trusts all of us and won't do it he
doesn't want to lose it all and he
thanked me uh specifically Avery said
yeah shout out of killer
yo I feel like we did a good dude here
today yeah I started off goofing a lot
at these clips and then we ended up
saving his whole life and career it's
beautiful
it would have gone broken up the second
time there here's an example of what
would have happened watch this
in Best Buy her mom son please do not
shoot up to Best Buy yeah you have so
much to live for so do not hurt the
employees
you don't want this happening in the
airport yeah exactly
you're a piece of [__]
you're a piece of [__] you're a piece of
[__] you're a piece of [__] the security
guard looks
bro
watch him go live when he's on the
airplane he thinks he's good because he
bought the inflate Wi-Fi he's like I got
it I got it all right I think we can uh
leave with a healthy and a good
conscious we've done something great
today people
feel good
and I hope that he's taking his mental
health uh seriously as well
but uh
we support you fousey
hi
and also it's okay to be gay I hope you
understand that
genuinely I the Freudian slip was
received
all right so who is gay so who is gay I
felt gay
all right guys I actually do have to go
now thank you all for watching what a
magical week it's been a magical Friday
we've had uh ups and downs and twists
and turns
Brian Singer don't sue me but it's fine
if you want to
you know what I mean
um people are pointing out that Abe just
saved another life
there you go add another one to your uh
roster baby thank you thank you just
what I do oh fusi just followed me I
know we we talked about it I just got
notified let's go
glad you are not streaming
the airport
there it is
all right
what more is there to say have a
fantastic weekend my friends I love you
thanks to all of our honored members who
make such a big difference we love you
guys the members we love you and thank
you we love everybody
and uh well we'll be back on Monday
for another week of fantastic shows
because this is the H3 podcast Nobody
Does it Like Us
good job on the sound bites thank you
good job Olivia on this down I had so
much fun thank you so much for allowing
me
and Zach will be back on Monday yes yes
indeed this is tough yeah he's he
definitely has a gift his fingers must
be in so much pain he's a musician
always like the entire time plays it
like a guitar he's good with his fingers
right here
all right everybody
be good
[Music]
foreign